monsieur le président pardonner ses
critiques préalable qui ne vous sont pas
adressés vous l'avez bien compris mais
qui s'adresse directement à l'exécutif
il devient crucial de démêler les enjeux
en présence devant la représentation
nationale nous voulons sortir de cette
audition en en sachant un peu plus sur
les contours et sur le calendrier de la
réforme et bien sûr son impact sur les
salariés sur les collectivités
territoriales
nous sortons dans ce contexte qui est un
peu anxiogène pour l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens nous souhaitons je
souhaiterais d'abord vous poser trois
séries de questions en premier lieu est
ce que vous pouvez nous préciser l'état
d'avancement du projet et reculent selon
la presse nous savons que cela pourrait
conduire à un partage des activités que
tout le monde a en tête certains
d'ailleurs ne disent pas partagent
certains disent démantèlement entre eux
de f bleu à capital public pour les
actions de nucléaire et de transport des
verts pour ouverte aux capitaux privés
pour les activités renouvelables de
distribution et de service et enfin le
dernier né edf azur quasi régis dédié
aux activités hydroélectriques
est ce bien ce schéma qui tient la corde
comment garantir je cite le caractère
intégré du groupe que vous aviez vous
même qualifié de fondamental lors de
votre dernière audition quelles seraient
les activités ouvertes aux capitaux
privés à quelle hauteur avec quels types
d'acteurs que répondez vous à ceux
d'entre nous qui considère que cette
réorganisation conduirait à nationaliser
les pertes et à privatiser les profits
du groupe
par ailleurs quel est le calendrier de
cette réforme note rapporteur pour avis
sur les crédits énergie que vous
connaissez daniel grémillet a obtenu de
la ministre de la transition écologique
devant le sénat le 13 janvier dernier
l'engagement public que le projet s'il
aboutit fasse l'objet d'un véhicule
juridique dédiée c'est la moindre des
choses
pensez vous qu'un texte puisse être donc
examinée avant la fin de ce quinquennat
enfin quelles sont les alternatives au
projet recul le mini de la ministre de
la transition écologique a indiqué
devant l'assemblée nationale
le 3 février dernier la nécessité
d'envisager un plan b je cite en cas
d'échec des négociations
réfléchissez vous à d'autres types
d'organisation pour reprendre la formule
de la ministre existe-t-il un projet
hector en lieu et place du projet
hercules en deuxième lieu le projet
recul est il à la hauteur des
difficultés financières d'edf selon la
presse ce projet aurait pour préalable
une réforme de la reine le dispositif de
régulation qui vend donc les tristes et
au prix 42 euros par mégawatt heure un
quart de sa production à ses concurrents
ce dispositif serait remplacé par un
corridor de prix d'après ce que nous
comprenons qui concernerait la totalité
de la production d'edf dans ses
perspectives la commission de régulation
de l'énergie aurait évalué à 48 euros le
coût de production de l'énergie contre
53 pour vos propres analyses
est ce que tout cela suffira à votre
bonheur et une autre donc par conséquent
je rappelle que le groupe edf est
confronté à un mur de dette avec une
dette de 40 2 milliards d'euros or vous
devez financer le grand carénage les
chantiers de lepers les investissements
en matière d'énergies renouvelables et
récemment ces dépenses ont été renchérit
par deux récentes déconvenues
la première de ces les contenus a trait
aux difficultés des chantiers d e p r et
la seconde bien sûr aux répercussions de
la crise de l'aco vide
19 enfin le projet recul est il de
nature à renforcer la compétitivité
l'énergie nucléaire par rapport aux
énergies renouvelables
nous vous entendre on sur ce sujet voilà
toute une série de questions préalables
je laisserais bien sûr mes collègues
vous posez beaucoup d'autres questions
je vais peut-être vous laisser la parole
sur un premier propos liminaire monsieur
le président et je vous autorise à
retirer votre masse passe
est ce que c'est vrai que c'est pas très
famille remercie pour votre invitation
et merci pour votre autorisation à ce
que au moment où je parle je puisse se
faire sans son masque
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénatrices et les
sénateurs j'ai bien compris à vos propos
que je vous parle des reculs et je vais
le faire je voudrais quand même dans le
temps qui nous est imparti qui est nous
permettra j'espère un véritable
véritable dialogue vous parler un petit
peu aussi du contexte pour edf vous avez
d'ailleurs vous même le madame la
présidente parler des éléments de
contexte et quelques mots aussi sur le
déploiement de notre stratégie
j'étais venu devant le sénat la dernière
fois en novembre 2019 dans des
conditions sanitaires évidemment
différente
et comme tous dfc ses salariés nous
avons dû faire face aux chocs absolument
inimaginable delà de la crise sanitaire
et du confinement des confinement je
voudrais d'abord vous dire que
l'entreprise edf a fait preuve d'une
mobilisation tout à fait extraordinaire
de ses salariés et je voudrais rendre
hommage aux salariés devant vous au plus
fort de la crise
notamment au début du premier
confinement il a fallu que les salariés
qui produisent l'électricité présents
chaque jour dans les usines du parc
nucléaire du parc hydraulique du parc
thermique du parc renouvelables ces
salariés ont assuré leur mission et à
chaque instant les ménages les services
publics et en particulier les hôpitaux
les collectivités les entreprises
l'ensemble des participants à la vie du
pays
aucun n'a jamais manqué l'électricité je
voulais le souligner je voudrais aussi
saluer la mobilisation des salariés de
notre filiale indépendante est née
disent qu'ils étaient présents sur le
terrain peut aussi en permanence la
continuité du service public pour
assurer le bon fonctionnement des
réseaux
les salariés d'edf au contact des
clients pendant toute cette période ne
pouvais plus aller sur leur lieu de
travail c'est d'ailleurs encore le cas
aujourd'hui puisque nous avons installé
des postes informatiques chez eux en
deux jours nous avons installé cinq
mille ordinateurs personnels pour que
les conseillers clientèle puis depuis
chez eux répondre aux clients qui les
appelle et comme contrairement à nos
concurrents
tous nos salariés au contact des clients
sont en france et non pas externaliser
dans des pays à bas salaires
et bien c'est c'est conseillers de
clientèle vivaient la même période la
même vie que nos clients et je crois
connaissent elles bien la situation
pouvait leur répondre de façon
appropriée
nous avons noté que nos clients à cette
époque et encore aujourd'hui ont marqué
une grande satisfaction sur la manière
dont le service d'edf leur a été fourni
donc malgré le confinement général la
fermeture des frontières le fait que les
transports de pièces détachées
étaient suspendus ou très perturbé df a
fait preuve de résilience
les salariés ont répondu présent et
personne n'a manqué d'électricité et
nous en sommes très fiers
la crise a donc rappelé combien
l'électricité fait partie de nos
services essentiels
la crise vous y avez fait allusion
madame la présidente a bien sûr des
conséquences économiques
un coût pour le groupe edf et le manque
à gagner en chiffre d'affaires nous
l'estimons à environ 2 milliards d'euros
et puis le planning de maintenance du
parc de production le parc de production
hydraulique et surtout le parc de
production nucléaire
nous avons dû adapter nos plannings ces
circonstances et donc la production
nucléaire de 2020 que nous avons
finalement produite c'est un peu plus de
330 5 térawattheures là où nous
craignons de ne pouvoir produire que 3
100 térawattheures nous avons finalement
produit 335 térawattheures mais ce
chiffre de 335 térawattheures s'est
néanmoins environ 12 % en dessous de
notre objectif initial
donc nous avons perdu 12% de la
production nucléaire par rapport à
allonnes l'objectif initial à cause de
cette très profonde désorganisation 4
qui a été notamment l'arrêt de tout un
tas de chantier de maintenance de
maintenance lourde ou simplement de
changement de combustible
les conséquences de cette d'organisation
sur le parc nucléaire nous avons attiré
l'attention
elles se prolongeront sur les deux
années qui suivante
néanmoins le passage de l'hiver qui
suscite toujours une attention
particulière se passe bien nous vivons
actuellement une période de froid c'est
la deuxième de l'année après celle de
il y à un mois la consommation
d'électricité est pratiquement revenu à
son niveau normal ce qui est une bonne
nouvelle puisque par rapport à ce qui
serait attendu si nous n'étions pas dans
la période actuelle de couvre-feu et de
la certain ralentissement économique en
tout cas la consommation d'électricité
est pratiquement au niveau au niveau
prévu et nous sommes très confiants que
même dans les
quelques jours de grand froid que nous
vivons nous serons en mesure de fournir
à nos clients toute l'électricité dont
ils ont besoin je souligne que rte
d'ailleurs communiqué il y a deux jours
sur le fait que cette période de grand
froid ne devrait pas inquiéter les
français quant à la disponibilité de
l'électricité
voilà donc pour résumer sur cet aspect
là l'année qui vient de se passer nous
rappelle les valeurs de l'entreprise edf
nous rappelle notre capacité de
mobilisation au service des besoins
essentiels du pays et je souligne sur
tout le territoire de la république et
sur la métropole mais également sur les
territoires plus lointain outre mer
deuxième point que je voulais partager
avec vous ces théories question de
stratégie à mon arrivée il ya six ans
j'ai fixé une stratégie et je la met en
oeuvre depuis elle s'appelle cap 2030
nous voulons être le champion français
et européen de la neutralité carbone
d'ailleurs c'est l'actualité avec la loi
que le gouvernement que le conseil des
ministres pardon a approuvé hier le
projet de loi en mai dernier au niveau
d'edf c'est par notre assemblée générale
que nous avons fixés notre mission
pérenne et nous avons donc adopté en
application de la loi pacte une raison
d'être
la raison d'être du groupe et des fl est
désormais inscrite dans les statuts de
l'entreprise
c'est un engagement nous nous sommes
engagés à construire un avenir
énergétique neutre en co2 conciliant
préservation de la planète bien être et
développement grâce à l'électricité et
grâce à des solutions et services
innovants
mon rôle c'est de faire en sorte que
cette stratégie se déploie au quotidien
donc multiplions les offres innovantes à
nos clients et je vais passer rapidement
des offres de rénovation des logements
c'est en pleine actualité nous avons
l'offre isi
pour permettre aux français de remplacer
leur chaudière polluantes au fioul ou au
gaz par des pompes à chaleur qui
consomment trois fois moins d'énergie et
les met presque plus de co2 des offres
pour optimiser la consommation des
français puisque la sobriété et un est
un aspect essentiel et notamment grâce
aux compteurs linky nous avons développé
des applications gratuites qui
permettent aux français qui sans qui
sort qui s'en servent régulièrement
d'optimiser d'après des calculs que nous
tenons à la disposition des experts
jusqu'à 12 % de leur consommation des
temps attentif grâce à ses algorithmes
nous avons lancé des offres pour
décarbonée les sites industriels en
électrifiant les process en particulier
dans les usines ou blanc les bâtiments
en valorisant la chaleur fatale c'est la
spécialité de dalkia et nous travaillons
à produire sur place de l'hydrogène bas
carbone avec des investissements faits
dans une société de la drôme qui
s'appelle mcphee est dans une nouvelle
filiale d'edf que j'ai créée il ya un
peu plus d'un an qui s'appelle aïnats
mix et puis un sujet majeur dans
l'évolution du mix énergétique du pays
c'est l'arrivée de en masse de la
mobilité électrique et donc nous avons à
travers notre société easy via un rôle
important pour équiper en bornes de
recharge les collectivités les parkings
de bureau les parkings d'immeubles les
usines et centres commerciaux
nous aussi sommes très présents et donc
à travers ses offres nous sommes
l'acteur de référence des deux grands
vecteurs de la lutte contre le
réchauffement de la planète
d'une part l'électricité décarbonés qui
se substitue au gaz au charbon et au
pétrole et d'autre part la sobriété dans
la consommation
côté production on va beaucoup parler
d'eux nucléaire mais je voudrais
rappeler que nous avons acquis une
position de leader
dans la filière naissante de l'éolien en
mer nous soutenons le développement
d'une capacité manufacturière nouvelles
sur le territoire français qui se
traduit notamment par la construction
d'une usine à saint nazaire à cherbourg
et au havre
nous avons aussi rénové récemment
plusieurs installations hydroélectriques
qu'on en parlait sur la dordogne aussi
aux sénateurs mais je citerai un grand
chantier le plus grand de nos chantiers
actuels qui s'est terminée l'an dernier
en isère sur la commune de gaver nous
venons d'annoncer que nous lance en
lançant une grande ferme solaire
flottante sur un axe sur une retenue
d'eau dans les hautes-alpes à hauteur de
20 mégawatts dans la production
nucléaire
nous observons l'intérêt de nouveaux
pays pour la technologie française je
citerai volontiers l'inde la république
tchèque ou la pologne j'étais moi-même
la semaine dernière le royaume uni nous
a renouvelé sa confiance à l'égard du
groupe edf
et ceci nous conforte dans notre
ambition de leadership occidental alors
que à la suite des travaux du giec et de
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie le
nucléaire bénéficie indiscutablement
d'un regain d'intérêt dans de nombreuses
régions du monde et à ce titre pour
préparer notre participation à ces
futurs programmes nous mettons en oeuvre
le programme ecsel de redressement des
compétences dans la filière nucléaire
française pour qu'elle soit prête quand
les pouvoirs publics décideront
d'engager la construction de nouveaux
réacteurs européenne france décision
nous le savons n'est pas prise enfin à
l'international nous gagnons de nombreux
appels d'offres dans des marchés très
concurrentiels
par exemple le domaine des services nous
allons exploiter la centrale de
rafraîchissement de la kingdom tower à
riad qui doit faire quelques centaines
de mètres de haut un c'est pas ces
parias nous fournissons my crosoft
google et bien d'autres en énergies
renouvelables grâce à des projets
éoliens et photovoltaïques aux
états-unis et dans d'autres régions du
monde ce qui nous permet de nous
habituer à un mode de fonctionnement de
deux des entreprises sur le marché de
l'énergie qui est un disque est
indiscutablement va aussi démarré en
europe nous sommes
l'acteur occidentale retenu par des
partenaires émiratis pour développer la
plus grande centrale solaire au monde 2
gigawatts de 1000 mégawatts
et puis dans le nucléaire je le
rappelais le royaume uni nous a fait
confiance
serein que les 'points et le
gouvernement de monsieur johnson a
annoncé en décembre il y a deux mois
qu'ils rentrent en discussions avec edf
pour que nous lie construisions dans la
foulée d'hinckley poynt deux nouveaux
réacteurs sur le site de sizewell deux
niveaux européenne dans le domaine des
compteurs numériques le programme linky
fait école
nous avons été retenus c'est un exemple
parmi d'autres pour installer plusieurs
millions de compteurs communicants en
inde
vous le voyez nous avons une stratégie
nous sommes une entreprise en mouvement
ou déployons notre stratégie dans de
nombreux domaines
ma conviction c'est que cette stratégie
qui est centrée sur la neutralité
carbone est la bonne stratégie et on
voit bien que ce sont les autres groupes
qui viennent d'autres aspects du secteur
énergétique en particulier les meilleurs
du pétrole qui viennent sur notre
terrain je vous rassure nous n'avons pas
l'intention d'aller sur le leur alors
pourquoi cette réforme hercules et bien
cette réforme est reculée est nécessaire
parce que notre développement notre
croissance nos investissements sont
gravement entravé par le niveau de la
dette que nous avons accumulé depuis des
années du fait de la régulation qu'on
appelle la reine est que nous avons
besoin d'investir si nous voulons rester
c'est bien mon ambition
si nous voulons rester un champion
français européen et mondial je vous
donnais des exemples ma conviction c'est
que nous pouvons faire une réforme cette
réforme en conservant un groupe intégré
c'est un point essentiel incontournable
est aussi un groupe ambitieux et non pas
un groupe en risque de déclassement
comme là où nous amènerait la situation
actuelle
donc quels sont les objectifs de la
réforme le principal enjeu
le point de départ de la réforme c'est
de mettre fin à la reine je l' ai déjà
dit je compare la reine un poison un
poison qui en dix ans a directement
contribué à faire d'edf un acteur
surendettés à cinq reprises
edf a été dégradée par les agences de
notation de la dette pour ne pas arrêter
nos investissements nous avons ces
dernières années cédé pour plus de 10
milliards d'euros d'actifs et nous avons
été recapitalisée à hauteur de 4
milliards d'euros dont 3 milliards
d'euros souscrits par l'état alors que
nous sommes déjà l'un des plus gros
emprunteurs parmi toutes les entreprises
de la zone euro premier ou deuxième
selon les années nous savons que sans la
présence de l'état au capital
nous devrions interrompre notre
programme d'investissement nous ne
pourrions plus le mettre en oeuvre
la reine est fondé sur une injustice
évidente la reine revient à
subventionner nos concurrents il nous
expose sans aucune limite sans plancher
comme on dit au prix de vente les plus
bas ils nous imposent en cas de prix de
marché élevée puisque les prix sur le
marché peuvent être bas ils peuvent être
élevés mais si les prix de marché sont
élevés ils nous imposent de ventre de
notre point de vendre notre production
nucléaire à un prix plafonné qui nous
couvre pas les coûts du parc de
production et qui n'a même pas été
réévaluée de l'inflation depuis dix ans
et je les vis depuis mon arrivée j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire fréquemment devant
devant vous mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs il est
primordial
il est de la plus haute importance que
nous puissions dès que possible mettre
fin à la règle et notre objectif c'est
de substituer à nouveau mécanisme de
régulation du nucléaire existant pour
apporter de la stabilité à nos clients
il faut donc que ce mécanisme soit
stable claires compréhensibles
symétrique qu'il ne traite pas de façon
obligatoire
edf moins bien que ses concurrents il
faut qu'il soit pérenne il faut qu'il
travaille on dans la durée nous sommes
industrie du temps long et il faut que
le niveau fixé pour la nouvelle le
nouveau prix de vente permet de
rémunérer le parc nucléaire à sa juste
valeur la réforme de la reine c'est donc
l'objectif numéro un de la réforme et je
crois pouvoir dire que cet objectif est
partagé par le gouvernement qui négocie
avec la commission européenne les
modalités de cette nouvelle régulation
j'ajouterai que cette nouvelle
régulation est nécessaire à la
préservation de la filière nucléaire
française qui est elle même une pièce
essentielle de la stratégie bas carbone
de notre pays le deuxième objectif de la
réforme c'est de donner au groupe edf
les moyens de se développer dans la
transition énergétique pendant encore
longtemps le nucléaire et l'hydraulique
vont rester les fondements essentiels de
notre mix électrique décarbonée mais
nous savons tous que la croissance
s'effectue d'abord par les
infrastructures d'énergie renouvelable
l'éolien à terre l'éolien en mer le
solaire dans de grandes fermes au sol
mais aussi le solaire en toiture et puis
ne les oublions pas les réseaux de
chaleur dans les villes qui recycle des
déchets industriels ou des déchets
ménagers pour produire de l'énergie
voilà où est la croissance je ne
voudrais pas oublier que la croissance
c'est aussi celle du réseau de
distribution est né dix dans
pratiquement toute la france le réseau
de distribution doivent acheminer
l'énergie créée par des centaines de
milliers d'installations très
décentralisé intermittente et le réseau
de distribution doit également
accompagner l'électrification des usages
par exemple quand un dépôt de bus passe
à l'électrique il faut bien kennedys il
a amené beaucoup plus d'électricité que
précédemment
et je voudrais dire à qu'à cet égard les
investissements des néo 10 sont en
hausse ces dernières années depuis 2015
les investissements des nez dit
ont augmenté de 30% les caractéristiques
de la transition énergétique nous amène
aussi à nous préoccuper de la gestion de
l'intermittence le développement du
stockage de développement progressif de
la production d'hydrogène bas carbone
pour l'industrie pour les transports
lourds fait partie de nos projets et
pour accompagner la décarbonation de
notre pays vous voyez que nous avons
besoin d'investissements nous avons
l'ambition d'être un acteur de premier
plan dans tous ces domaines
ces investissements sont significatifs
et de plus nous devons investir
directement dans des moyens de
production ou dans des réseaux mais
aussi dans des innovations qui nous
permettront d'être à l'affût de ce qui
se passe partout dans le monde et
d'opérer un réseau qui comme aujourd'hui
donnera aux français à système
électrique comme aujourd'hui donnera aux
français un avantage compétitif en
termes de pouvoir d'achat je ne crois
que personne ne discute mais l'enjeu
sans réforme d'edf c'est que comment
allons-nous hésiter le déclassement
d'edf par rapport aux grands groupes
européens qui ont désormais parce qu'ils
n'ont pas la reine qui ont désormais des
moyens et donc des rythmes de
développement très supérieur au nôtre
de ce fait plusieurs grands groupes
européens ont déjà pris une réelle
avance et annoncent publiquement des
objectifs à l'horizon 2030 très
supérieur à ce que peut envisager edf
dans sa configuration actuelle et
j'aurai des chiffres à vous donner si
vous le souhaitez le troisième objectif
stratégique de la réforme qui est arrivé
un petit peu au moment où on
réfléchissait au bono bonne structure en
liaison avec l'état
troisième objectif sécuriser nos
concessions hydroélectriques
vous le savez nous sommes depuis 20 ans
sous la menace même sort dans une
profonde remise en cause du modèle
d'exploitation des barrages
hydroélectriques en france la mise en
concurrence des concessions lorsqu'elle
expire pourrait progressivement
démantelée la cohérence du parc
hydraulique qui a été construit depuis
un siècle et même un peu plus d'un
siècle disiez-vous le tout début
10 20e siècle notre perception qui je
crois a largement partagé par les très
nombreux utilisateurs de l'eau et par
les collectivités locales
c'est que la traduction de la directive
européenne sur les concessions de 1998
porte en germe une des optimisations du
productible hydraulique et un
appauvrissement des vallées concernés
dans le contexte du changement
climatique dont les effets sont de plus
en plus visible l'enjeu de la gestion de
l'eau à croix cette préoccupation nous
voulons donc préserver et développer
libre olic qui est née une énergie
pilotable et verte riche d'emplois
qualifiés et entraînant derrière elle
l'activité économique dans des zones
montagneuses
comment atteindre dans notre projet
comment atteindre ces trois objectifs
stratégiques et où en est la négociation
je dois d'abord vous dire que c'est
l'état bien évidemment qui mène les
négociations avec la commission
européenne
df est amené à se coordonner
régulièrement avec les tâches
qualifierais cette coordination de deux
permanentes de quotidienne je vous
dirais bien volontiers que je me réjouis
de l'excellente alignement entre l'état
et l'entreprise que je dis riches
nous avons déterminé ensemble des lignes
rouges la ministre madame barbara pompe
il y en a donné les grandes lignes la
semaine dernière devant l'assemblée
nationale et nous les faisons nôtre vous
avez dit il ya des questions sur le
groupe intégré je le dis très très
fortement devant la représentation
nationale
le groupe edf doit rester un groupe
public intégré ça veut dire un groupe
dans lequel d'abord il n'existe qu'une
seule stratégie les différentes entités
au sein du groupe ne se font pas
concurrence entre elles
au contraire elle coopère un groupe
intégré c'est aussi un groupe où les
salariés peuvent circuler d'une entité à
l'autre pour développer leur potentiel
et progresser c'est un groupe où
existent
des fonctions qui ont été mises en
commun des fonctions mutualisé qui
apporte une meilleure efficacité
meilleure créativité qui apporte aussi
des économies d'échelle
s'agissant d'edf c'est aussi un groupe
qui conserve sa marque la marque bf est
une marque magnifique très apprécié des
français n'est pas question d'en changer
c'est un groupe aussi où le statut des
industries électriques et gazières
auxquelles sont attachées les salariés
très nombreux qui sont dans l'entreprise
sous ce statut
c'est un statut qui n'est donc pas
remise en cause et je le répète une
nouvelle fois il n'est pas remise en
cause
je pense que le caractère intégré du
groupe edf est une des clés du succès du
modèle énergétique français depuis des
décennies notre modèle se traduit par un
positionnement qui englobe tous les
maillons de la chaîne de valeurs de
l'électricité qui couvre toutes les
filières de production et qui couvre
tous les services y compris les plus
innovants c'est un ensemble homogène
c'est un atout pour la france
il doit être conservé sur le plan
économique la réforme doit bien sûr
garantir que le prix de la future
régulation nucléaire couvre les coûts et
rémunère les investissements du parc
existant ce qui n'est pas le cas des 42
euros du mégawattheures ou non à
augmenter de l'inflation non indexé avec
lequel nous vivons depuis dix ans enfin
dans la réforme
le groupe edf doit disposer des moyens
de se développer dans tous les métiers
de la transition énergétique et
notamment dans les énergies
renouvelables pour que nous restions un
acteur de premier plan comme l'a déclaré
la ministre un accord qui ne répondrait
pas à ces objectifs ne serait pas
acceptable
la négociation est actuellement toujours
en cours
j'avais décrit devant vous lorsque
j'étais venu fin 2019
ma dernière audition les grandes lignes
du projet je vais donc les rappeler
brièvement le projet repose sur une
réorganisation du groupe intégré edf en
deux parties complémentaires et jamais
concurrentes
chacune de ces partis disposant d'actifs
homogène et d'objectifs stratégiques
claires première entité serait un
ensemble que l'on appelle edf bleus
regroupés en la production nucléaire la
production thermique la production
hydraulique est en elle transférée à une
quasi régis détenue à 100% par edf bleu
un dieu deuxième ensemble serait
constitué que l'on appelle edf vert
regroupant la distribution les services
les activités commerciales la
construction et l'exploitation des
énergies renouvelables et nos activités
à l'international
le premier ensemble vous le voyez c'est
le monde de la production centralisée le
deuxième ensemble c'est le monde des
centralisme pour le nucléaire dans les
df bleus l'enjeu essentiel c'est la
nouvelle régulation pour le parc
nucléaire existant
le mécanisme je les dis doit être
symétrique contrairement à la reine il
est prévu on avait parlé un moment d'un
corridor aujourd'hui on parle d'un prix
fixe
vc je dirais un sujet qui est un petit
peu du deuxième ordre d'importance et
niveau du prix ou le niveau du dessus de
la médiane du corridor donc aujourd'hui
ça serait un préfixe ce set ce prix
cette électricité à prix fixe
électricité nucléaire serait accessible
à tous les commercialisateurs dans les
mêmes conditions sans pénaliser edf au
bénéfice de ses concurrents tous les
commercialisateurs sera mis dans les
mêmes conditions et le niveau de prix il
est en négociation il faudra qu'ils
couvrent effectivement les coûts du parc
nucléaire il existe et existants et les
investissements passés et futurs de ce
parc nucléaire nous savons que ce n'est
pas le cas de la reine actuelle pour
l'hydraulique l'état et edf nous avons
conçu une
voient un moyen pour protéger notre
patrimoine hydraulique
c'est le moyen de la quasi régis une
forme de société détenue à 100% par le
secteur public et cette forme de quasi
régie permet une exception au droit
européen des concessions ce modèle
juridique qui n'est pas pratiquée de
façon très courante mais qui existent
comporte de nombreuses spécificités
notamment de gouvernance ce modèle
permet la détention totale de notre
patrimoine hydraulique et pérenne par le
groupe edf ce qui concerne les autres
activités en particulier les activités
de transition énergétique la nouvelle
organisation donnerait bien plus de
moyens au groupe edf pour investir et
accompagner ses clients à travers sa
filiale contrôlée
edf vers ces sociétés des verts
bénéficiera de financement propre et
pourra se développer beaucoup plus
rapidement pour faire du groupe intégré
edf un acteur de premier plan de la
transition énergétique
la croissance de nos activités dans la
transition énergétique serait très
supérieur à la situation actuelle et
devrait nous permettre de rattraper le
retard indiscutable et croissants que
nous prenons sur plusieurs grands
groupes européens
bien évidemment des verts seraient
détenus très majoritairement par edf
bleus et resterait dans le secteur
public des verts l'inclura aînés 10 ce
qui lui permettra d'avoir d'un côté un
distributeur puissant réguler et de
l'autre des activités renouvelables
commerciales et de service ce modèle
n'est pas nouveau le modèle 2d est versé
celui retenu par nos grands concurrents
européens et je vais les cités notamment
iberdrola société espagnole nl société
italienne
ce sont eux qui nous sont passés devant
ces dernières années sur ce modèle d'edf
r
le réseau de distribution est en effet
un vecteur essentiel de la transition
énergétique et pour aînés disent leur
attachement à edf vers centré sur la
mise en oeuvre d'une transition qui est
par nature décentralisée en lien étroit
avec les territoires confortera ses
missions de service public et n'est dit
ce serait tout simplement la filiale à
100% d'edf vers commune et 17
aujourd'hui à 100%
la filiale d'edf ce serait les mêmes
missions de service public garanti par
la loi mais la même indépendance de
gestion des néo 10 sous le contrôle de
notre régulateur sectoriel la commission
de régulation de l'énergie
et bien entendu la péréquation tarifaire
sera maintenu voilà ma conviction c'est
que cette réforme que je viens de vous
décrire et je pensais qu'il était
important même en ayant dépassé un petit
peu le temps de vous donner le contexte
et la situation d'edf
je crois que cette réforme est une vraie
opportunité de développement pour le
groupe edf au service de la neutralité
carbone et de la transition énergétique
j'ai juste pour conclure vous donner un
chiffre nous visons aujourd'hui 50
gigawatts
retenez ce chiffre de 50 de capacité
renouvelables à l'horizon 2030 dans dix
ans nos calculs nous montre qu'avec la
réforme nous pouvons viser un doublement
de cette capacité renouvelables monte de
50 à 100 gigawatts avoir un rôle deux
fois plus important dans la transition
énergétique que là où nous amène la
situation actuelle que je qualifierais
volontiers d'impasse voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire en propos introductif
et madame la présidente je suis
maintenant dans vos mains est prêt à
répondre à vos questions
merci monsieur le président je pense que
vos propos à peine rond à un grand
nombre de questions en tout cas merci
pour ces propos liminaire je vais donner
d'abord la parole à nos deux rapporteurs
pour avis au budget énergie que sont
d'abord daniel grémillet et patrick
chauvet ensuite vous répondre et
peut-être à leurs questions et ensuite
j'ouvrirai la salle aux autres questions
dans les modalités habituelles un petit
peu voilà le sujet est très très
important donc on fera preuve de
souplesse
daniel grémillet donc oui merci madame
l'un présente
merci messieurs président de ce ce
propos pour une partie d'ailleurs je
suis avait l'impression hunawihr accuse
à une transmission penser puisque vous
avez déjà répondu quasiment à ma
première question qui est vraiment
d'actualité donc solennellement
aujourd'hui en commission des affaires
économiques du sénat vous confirmer bien
ne vous inquiétez pas en france ne
seront en capacité de produire l'énergie
électrique nécessaire à nos concitoyens
et à notre économie est compris dans des
situations de froid tels que nous sommes
en train de vivre aujourd'hui je crois
que ce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
est très important parce
qu'effectivement il ya un doute qui
s'est installé il ya des questionnements
qui se sont positionnés par contre il y
aurait je n'en ai pas parlé du très long
terme oms le sénateur jouer à mes jeux
ludiques dans les jours qui viennent il
n'y aura pas de problème je pense que
les années qui viennent j'espère aussi
mais comme vous le savez s'il ya de très
très longues de froid encore plus
intense qu'aujourd'hui à un moment donné
les experts vous expliqueront qu'ils
atterrissent
mais ce court terme les choses sont dans
de bonnes mains non monsieur le
président justement let laissez-moi
aller au bout de ma question
vous l'avez avec une grande précaution
précisé qu'on est dans des situations
effectivement et s'était confirmée par
arte aussi situation 2021 2022 2023 ne
sont pas dans une capacité
d'augmentation production d'énergie
électrique énorme faut dire les choses
comme elles sont donc le risque
effectivement avec les précautions vous
n'êtes prendre existe par contre le
point sur lequel je veux vous entendre
si ces situations conjoncturellement
actuellement peut passer on est aussi
aidée elle a subi hélas parce qu'on
préférerait tous au contraire par la
situation de pandémie qui harland qui
ralentit aujourd'hui un peu notre
activité qu'elles soient industrielles
qu'elle soit je pense ou retour restera
qu'un enfant toutes les activités qui y
sont consommatrices d'énergie et souvent
d'énergie électrique
donc effectivement c'est un premier
point ce nous espérons tous s'en sortir
et bien sûr avant 2023 et ma deuxième
question sur ce sujet la france
à juste titre on sait tous qu'on a
besoin si au niveau de l'emploi de
retrouver une capacité de production
industrielle veut re localiser des
activités industrielles de production
qui dit activités industrielles de
production du besoin énergétique et on
le voit déjà sur nos territoires
ça sera fait pour certaines régions
avant 2023 pour nous avons assisté à un
certain nombre d'entreprises ont été la
lauréate de concours financier à la fois
du plan de relance est à la fois des
régions pour le faire et c'est en cours
donc comment pourrons-nous bien vivre
cette situation
deuxième point sur lequel je souhaitais
vous interrogez vous avez été assez
claire sur les concessions hydrauliques
jamais pensé que la france voulait dire
comme les allemands à la commission des
affaires européennes c'est comme ça j'ai
compris que ça sera pas comme ça en
clair on va vers une adaptation parce
que là aussi a beaucoup d'inquiétudes
sur ses concessions hydroélectriques
vous avez
juste dit parler aussi de territoires
qui sont très attachés à cela mais au
sénat nous sommes très attachés aussi à
souveraineté de production énergétique
qui pouvait aussi à nous amener à des
positionnements assez puissant par
contre est-ce que vous pourriez très
rapidement nous de redonner les
concessions exploitée par edf qui sont
concernés par le sujet ça concerne
effectivement au niveau de nos
territoires
un certain nombre de sites ma dernière
question
ce prêt lyon concerne l'impact la loi
énergie climat sur les activités d'edf
et notamment des fait face la fermeture
des quatre centrales à charbon d'ici
un des 14 réacteurs ouvert d'ici 2035
leur projet de reconversion et
combustion vise à faire passer la
centrale de cordemais du charbon la
biomasse at il progressé et comment se
prépare le démantèlement des deux
réacteurs de la centrale de fessenheim
est à l'arrêt depuis 2000 ventes
al'inverse comment udf entente elle
tirer profit des incitations des en
faveur des énergies renouvelables en
particulier en matière
d'hydroélectricité d'éolien en mer et
l'hydrogène bas carbone
ces investissements dans ce domaine at
il affecté a été affecté par la crise de
coheed comme vous l'avez tout à l'heure
évoquée sur le maintien des de nos
centrales nucléaires que vous pensez
vous de la révision des contrats d'achat
des installations photovoltaïques de
plus de 250 kilowatts adoptée par le
gouvernement dans le cadre du projet de
loi de finances 2011 21 les projets
d'éolien en mer sont ils confrontés à
des difficultés de mise en oeuvre à
l'instar de celui de dunkerque qui fait
l'objet d'un conflit avec la belgique
avez vous un avis sur l' ordonnance en
cours sur l'hydrogène
la commission de régulation la crue
commission de régulation de l'énergie
cre eux ayant invité à ne pas distinguer
l'hydrogène nucléaire l hydrogène
renouvelables dans le soutien apporté
par la filière et enfin monsieur le
président quinn de la taxe omrani verte
en cours de négociation qui semble
favoriser l'éolien et le solaire par
rapport à l'hydroélectricité et au
nucléaire
notre second rapporteur budget si
répondre aux deux messieurs merci madame
la présidente monsieur le directeur
général mes chers collègues d'abord
merci monsieur le président directeur
général de votre présence parce que le
sujet recul a suscité et suscite
beaucoup de questions y compris en
interne parmi les équipes les équipes
d'edf madame la ministre dans un premier
débat ici avait l'air surprise du nombre
de questions ou de contrevérités je
pense qu'il y à un manque de
communication au départ de ce projet qui
suscite beaucoup de questions voire des
inquiétudes pour positiver
moi j'y vois un attachement historique à
cette belle entreprise française et que
du coup je vous remercie de votre
présence dans un objectif de
clarification mon interrogation est donc
double en premier lieu je souhaiterais
vous interroger sur l'incidence du
projet recul sur les filiales d'edf est
né dix qui assure la distribution
d'électricité et réseau de transport
d'électricité rte en charge de son
transport pour ce qui concerne et 10 la
fédération nationale des collectivités
concédantes et régies fnccr est très
inquiète de l'ouverture aux capitaux
privés d'edf vert dans lequel seraient
localisées aînés 10 selon elle cette
évolution poserait sur l'indépendance
financière des néo 10 et à terme sur la
dynamique d'investissement la qualité du
service et le prix pour les usagers
quel est votre point de vue sur cette
inquiétude
comment garantir que le projet recul
n'est pas d'app
sur l'indépendance financière nenê
disent les missions de service du
service public de la distribution
les contrats de concession des
collectivités territoriales les tarifs
d'utilisation du réseau public de
distribution d'électricité ou encore le
principe de la péréquation tarifaire
pourquoi les autorités organiseraient
organisatrice de la distribution
d'électricité ne sont elles pas associé
au projet de réforme alors qu'elles sont
concernés au premier chef
s'agissant de rte le président de la
commission de régulation de l'énergie a
indiqué le 15 juillet dernier que la
perspective d'une fusion de rte détenu
par edf et de grt gaz détenu par angie
au sein d'un grand ensemble n'était ni
murs ni mort que pensez vous de cette
éventualité
en second lieu je souhaiterais également
vous interroger sur les répercussions
des réformes du marché de l'électricité
sur les salariés du groupe et les
entreprises électro intensives pour ce
qui concerne les salariés du groupe vous
avez indiqué lors de votre dernière
audition que le projet et recul devrait
respecter je cite le statut des salariés
qui pourront continuer de passer d'une
entité à l'autre dont acte
au delà de la question du statut
pouvez-vous nous assurer que ce projet
ne conduira pas des cessions d'activités
et à des suppressions d'emplois à
l'image de la restructuration actuelle
d' angie
quant aux entreprises électro intensives
elles sont très préoccupés de leur
éventuelle exclusion du dispositif de
régulation qui pourraient remplacer la
reine partagez vous leur préoccupation
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le président je
vous laisse répondre à ces deux
premières interventions
oui puisque je vais vous croyez vous
aviez dire à ses deux premières
questions j'avais noté plus plus d'une
question
surprise j'ai dit je vais essayer de
répondre aussi bien aux sénateurs
grémillet qu'aux sénateurs chauvet en
essayant de répondre à l'essentiel des
des questions qui ont été posées dans
début de son intervention le sénateur
grémillet s'inquiète de la continuité de
la fourniture je me suis permis de vous
interrompre pour vous dire que nous
n'avons pas ce souci de court terme edf
n'en a pas et retenant n'a pas ces
terres théo qui s'exprime et df est le
principal producteur don qu'il voit bien
quel est le niveau de production qu'il
peut atteindre et ses terres théo qui
fait la synthèse entre l'offre de
courant qui est produit et la demande
telle qu'il la voit en fonction d'eux
des prévisions qui évidemment dépendent
du jour de la semaine mais dépendent
aussi du temps qui fait de la
température qui fait la température
ressentie
il voit aussi des productions qui ne
s'est pas chez edf et en particulier la
production intermittente d'énergie
éolienne qui certains jours de froid est
très faible
là actuellement elle était plutôt à un
niveau moyen de production meilleur que
la production d'énergie éolienne que
nous avions vécu au mois de janvier et
qui avait amené nos collègues de rte à
émettre un message de vigilance
vis-à-vis des français
ce que je crois ils n'ont pas fait pour
la phase de froid que nous que nous
vivons actuellement donc sur la
continuité de la fourniture à court
terme
nous n'avons pas de soucis sur la
continuité de la fourniture à moyen
terme moi je ne saurais vraiment vous
donner d'indication je crois que je ne
serai pas très crédible vous à vous dire
dormez sur vos deux oreilles tout va
très bien
quoi qu'il arrive pendant dix ans
pendant un temps pendant dix siècles
pendant vingt siècles
les français auront toute l'électricité
qu'ils ont besoin dont ils auront besoin
je crois que le rôle des dirigeants qui
comme moi sont amenés à à prendre des
décisions sur le long terme c'est
d'essayer en permanence d'inscrire
leur leurs décisions d'investissement ou
les décisions qu'ils présentent en
l'occurrence au conseil d'administration
d'edf et à l'état de les inscrire dans
une dans une perspective qui par
définition est délicate que nous sommes
d'autres dans des industries qui
investissons dans des infrastructures
qui vont durer des dizaines et des
dizaines d'années mais elles vont toutes
se rassembler pour fournir du courant
électrique dans un pays dont on ne sait
pas très bien ce qu'il en sera sur le
plan démographique sur le plan
économique sur le plan du comportement
des consommateurs en matière de sobriété
et puis sur le plan de la grande
transition vers l'électricité puisque
nous allons de plus en plus nous loger
avec des pompes à chaleur donc avec du
courant électrique et nous allons de
plus en plus nous transporter avec soi
des batteries chimiques qui auront
nécessité du courant électrique pour
être chargée soit peut-être pour
certaines applications de l'hydrogène
qui aura été lui-même fabriqué en
cassant avec des courants électriques la
molécule d'eau même façon dans des
processus industriels peut-être dans des
processus agricole nous allons de plus
en plus voir l'utilisation de
l'électricité et donc à l'horizon de 20
ou 30 ans la la la la la certitude que
l'on peut avoir sur l' équilibre du du
système électrique est évidemment moi
moi moi fort parce que à l'horizon de
quelques jours dans ce cadre le
gouvernement a demandé à rte et à
laguiole agence internationale de
l'énergie de fournir des scénarios à
l'horizon 2030
une première étude a été rendue publique
il ya quelques jours et on nous dit qu'à
l'automne une deuxième étude plus
complète avec des des calculs
économiques ce qui n'est pas le cas de
la première étude sera rendue nous nous
pensons je l'affirmé volontiers même un
peu en avance de phase par rapport à la
sollicitation que nous allons avoir que
dans le cadre des travaux donc demandé
par le gouvernement a alerté et à l'oeil
nous allons dire que nous pensons qu'il
serait extrêmement dangereux pour
assurer la continuité de la fourniture
de l'électricité aux français à un
horizon de 15 20 ans voire au delà
il serait extrêmement dangereux de se
priver d'électricité nucléaire
la certitude tous les gens que je
rencontre chez edf sait qu'on peut
imaginer on peut dans une dans un monde
magique imaginé qu'on puisse se passer
d'électricité nucléaire en france
mais pour cette personne ne peut
vraiment dire quelles seraient les
conséquences d'un tel choix
les conséquences en termes de coûts le
coût pour la collectivité par exemple d'
artificialisation des sols par exemple
de de perte de l'indépendance nationale
puisque beaucoup de choses sont importés
en matière de coût économique pour le
pouvoir d'achat des français
je le répète bien volontiers qu'ils
bénéficient d'une électricité nettement
moins chers que leurs que leurs voisins
et puis deux coups des discontinuités
s'il devait y avoir du fait de ses choix
peut-être des pannes de courant
je rappelle qu'il y à des pays très
avancés qui pas seulement des pays en
développement il ya des idées très
avancé camp du mal à équilibrer leurs
systèmes électriques et dans lesquels il
y à des coupures de courant rares mais
elles existent il n'y en a pas en france
donc nous allons répondre que la
continuité de la fourniture
d'électricité dans le très long terme
dépend de choix d'investissement qui
doivent être faites dans le très court
terme et qui doivent intégrer de
l'électricité nucléaire et d
ou réacteurs nucléaires et à ce titre
nous nous répondrons dans la foulée de
ce que des f a dit depuis longtemps
c'est que il nous faut le plus vite
possible être autorisés à construire six
nouveaux aux pères parce que sinon eh
bien nous prendrons des risques sur tous
les aspects que je viens de citer
et nous allons en plus affaiblir une
filière nucléaire dont on a bien vu le
la faiblesse qu'elle avait au moment du
démarrage de flamanville a redémarré des
chantiers après avoir interrompu pendant
si longtemps de construire de nouvelles
centrales nucléaires
donc voilà ce que ce que je voulais dire
monsieur le sénateur en réponse à votre
question sur la continuité de la de la
sécurité d'approvisionnement donc nous
nous allons militer jusqu'à ce que nous
j'espère nous arrivions à convaincre que
sans nucléaire
nous ferions prendre des risques
considérables sur beaucoup de sujets
majeurs un autre pic
bien évidemment c'est l'état qui en
décidera le moment venu ce qui concerne
les les concessions expiré d'abord on
vous donnera bien volontiers la liste
dès que la liste des concessions qui ont
expiré
c'est une liste qui a augmenté chaque
année des concessions qui expire pendant
l'année par définition et c'est de ce
sont les concurrents les concessions sur
lesquelles la commission nous demande en
application d'une directive qui a été
approuvé par la france il ya une
vingtaine d'années qui a été transposée
en droit français de m ces concessions
en concurrence le demandent à l'état
français d'organiser des appels d'offres
et
elle voudrait même qu edf dans certains
cas puisse ne même pas répondre à cet
appel d'offres pour être sûr que ça sera
pas nous savait que la commission ne
nous aiment pas beaucoup
un job dit volontiers dans le jeu
connaît le côté très discret de ses
auditions savait que la commission
n'aime pas beaucoup edf en direct et
donc faisons en sorte qu edf ne
répondent pas à tous parce qu'il s'agit
quand même pas qu'il ya un an edf trop
fort en france la quasi régie est un est
un régime qui existe dans le droit
européen et des discussions ont eu lieu
entre le gouvernement français et la
commission et le gouvernement nous dit
les services de l'état nous explique
nous explique oui la quasi régie serait
un moyen de faire échapper les
concessions qui expire au fur et à
mesure un régime de mise en concurrence
et donc comme vous l'avez entendu dans
mon propos liminaire nous pensons que
dans l'un de ces trois volets le passage
de nos activités hydrauliques dans le
régime de la quasi régie pour leur
donner non seulement une pérennité et
une efficacité nous pensons que la mise
en concurrence
en l'occurrence serait source
d'inefficacité en démembrant les vallées
dans lesquelles plusieurs opérateurs
pourraient intervenir de façon
indépendants les uns des autres mais
aussi de manière à ce que nos activités
hydrauliques puisse à nouveau
recommencer à construire le potentiel
hydraulique de la france est assez bien
couvert mais il ya quand même des choses
à faire pour améliorer encore le
productible comme on dit chez nous le
productible en matière de production
hydraulique est aujourd'hui avec la la
la les incertitudes juridiques autour de
la mise en concurrence et
les mises en demeure des deux mises en
demeure qui a reçu la france est bien
tout cela est à l'arrêt et nous perdons
en fait l'opportunité de mieux utiliser
l'eau qui tombe du ciel pour produire de
l'électricité
on avait ensuite parlé des moyens de
production qui ferment je vous dirais
sur fessenheim que comme vous le savez à
notre grand regret les deux réacteurs
sont définitivement arrêtée depuis le
milieu de l'année dernière le deuxième
réacteur à fermer et donc nous
appliquons les réglementations et
pendant quelques années nous sommes en
train de libérer le site d'un certain
nombre de des activités industrielles
qui étaient les siennes et de préparer
le chantier de déconstruction
pendant ce temps là nous venons à
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
les informations dont nous aurons besoin
pour que ce chantier de coût des
constructions qui est une activité
nucléaire puisque pouvant toucher à des
matières nucléaires se fasse avec un
accord de l'autorité sûreté nucléaire
dont il faut normalement cinq ans entre
l'arrêt de la centrale et le démarrage
je dirais actifs de l'activité de
démantèlement sur sur fessenheim ce qui
concerne les centrales au charbon
gouvernement a donc prévu qu'elle
s'arrête nous avons aujourd'hui deux
unités sur le site de cordemais qui je
crois ce matin fonctionne bien et c'est
bien utile puisqu'il fait froid et nous
avons aussi une unité sur le site du
havre qui je crois fonctionne aussi en
cette période de froid il faudrait que
le je le vérifie pour ce matin et la
centrale du havre vivent ces derniers
jours de fonctionnement puisque à la fin
du mois de mars elle arrêtera
définitivement de fonctionner comme ont
arrêté de fonctionner de très nombreuses
centrales au charbon
qui avait été l'équipement principal du
pays où l'un des équipements principaux
du pays dans les années 50 ou 60 un
projet éco combis ce que de reconversion
de la centrale de cordemais est à
l'étude des aspects environnementaux
logistique économique de ce projet sont
compliquées donc nous travaillons
étroitement avec les services de l'état
avec les services du ministère de la
transition écologique pour essayer de
d'examiner la viabilité d'un tel projet
qui n'est pas aujourd'hui décider vous
m'avez interrogé
si j'ai bien compris sur différents
différentes conséquences du coc vite sur
nos chantiers et je dirais que nous
avons pu nous organiser pour faire
passer en priorité sur les chantiers
pendant le notamment le premier
confinement au printemps les salariés
qui étaient sur le chemin critique et
que donc sur le chantier le plus
important pour nous qui est celui de
flamanville 3 nous n'avons pas observé
de retard qu'ils soient liés à cette
période c'est un chantier dans les
calendes le calendrier reste très tendue
nous commençons à réparer les soudures
qui sont très très sophistiquée et donc
ne je maintiens que le chantier de
flamanville 3 devrait se terminer à la
fin de l'année prochaine et voir sans le
chargement du combustible dans les
derniers jours où les dernières semaines
de l'année 2022
en ce qui concerne l'éolien en mer nous
avions au moment du premier confinement
commencer la construction du chantier
d'éolien en mer de saint nazaire
nous avons depuis décidé la construction
du chantier d'éolien en mer de fécamp à
ma connaissance aucun de ces deux
chantiers donc veolia et norbert à saint
nazaire et celle de fécamp ne souffre
d'un retard qu vide ce qui concerne le
chantier de dunkerque nous sommes dans
les premières années l'attribution est
encore récente
nous avons gagné cet appel d'offre
contre je crois cette autre concurrent
nous sommes très fiers d'avoir fait la
meilleure offre
il est exact que des discussions ont
lieu avec la belgique qui conteste qu'on
croise droit de la france a opéré sur
dunkerque et nous espérons que ceux ci
trouvera une jours d'août pas une une
solution paisible m'avait interrogé sur
la révision des contrats d'achat de
photovoltaïque qui correspondent à une
certaine période et donc l'état
avec le pardon l'état avec le concours
du parlement puisqu'il a fait voter la
loi n'est ce pas pas vous et du conseil
constitutionnel donc l'état n'a pas
honoré les engagements économiques qu'il
avait pris vis-à-vis de ceux qui ont
construit ces installations conseil
constitutionnel valide et tout cela est
donc nous allons seuls le président
d'edf à la parole cheikh président de la
haute loire
pardon ça nous rend donc perplexe sur la
gestion de projet qui pour beaucoup ont
été mis pour moins partiellement dans
les mains d'acteurs financiers donc
d'agents de gens qui gèrent notre
épargne aequo derrière finalement ce qui
est fait peut mettre en péril pour
certains épargnants une partie de
l'argent qu'ils ont mis de côté donc la
confiance qui peut y avoir dans les
investissements en france c'est un est
un sujet qui je pense préoccupe beaucoup
de beaucoup de gens dans cette salle et
nous allons pour ce qui nous concerne
devoir rentrer dans des discussions avec
l'administration sur la mise en oeuvre
pratique de cette décision
et puis vous m'avez parlé de deux sujets
taxonomie j'espère après avoir à peu
près tout noté monsieur le sénateur
grémillet la toxine hamid l'hydrogène
sur lequel les choses se présentent pas
trop mal et la taxonomie verte en europe
sur lequel la situation est quand même
abracadabrante puisque l'europe qui se
fait fort de vouloir aller vers la
décarbonation l'europe qui fait du green
deal
le premier des objectifs qu'elle se fixe
pour son nouveau quinquennat une fois
les élections européennes de 2019 achevé
la commission mise en place
l'europe dit voilà pour moi l'alpha et
l'oméga c'est le green deal et vis-à-vis
du nucléaire l'europe a une vision
totalement éloignée de toute approche
scientifique de toute approche
cartésienne sous certaines influences
que je
saurait qualifier parce que ce n'est pas
mon rôle on voit bien que l'europe
cherche à évincer ou en tout cas ne pas
le reconnaître le nucléaire comme un
moyen de produire de l'électricité en
limitant considérablement les émissions
de dioxyde de carbone en faisant une
électricité qui est disponible à la
demande qu'on appelle dispatch à bhl et
non pas une électricité intermittente en
construisons des moyens de production
qui nécessitent des emplois locaux et
non pas des importations ou très peu
d'importations de matériel étranger et
donc il y à une incohérence que nous
dénonçons entre l'europe qui dit
publiquement que c'est le réchauffement
de la planète qui est le premier de ces
objectifs et une europe qui voudrait
exclure le financement du nucléaire des
standards qu'elle préconise sur les
marchés financiers le gouvernement
français c'est à huit autres
gouvernements européens pas la malle pas
une majorité au sein des 27 mai doivent
pas et point de dix au total se sont
élevés contre cette proposition en
matière de taxonomie mais nous ne sommes
pas majoritaires
nous sommes évidemment stupéfait de voir
la tournure que prennent que prennent
les choses et je dirais c'est peut-être
aussi liées aux os sujet recul dont on
va parler tout à l'heure je dirais que
la manière dont les services de la
commission européenne aborde ces sujets
qui touchent qui touche à l'énergie qui
touche à la décarbonation qui touche au
rôle des acteurs européens c'est quelque
chose qui en tant que président d'edf
m'interpelle quant à la quant à la
manière de traiter les acteurs européens
surtout moi qui viens du monde du
numérique
quand j'ai vu la manière différenciée
on va dire dont ont été traités dans
l'histoire encore et encore récemment
les opérateurs européens notamment dans
les télécoms qu'ils soient fournisseurs
ou
exploitant de réseau et les grands
opérateurs extra-européens qu'on appelle
qu'on appelle les gars femme là j'y vois
quelque chose d'un peu similaire comme
je l'aï dit à plusieurs reprises
je m'étonne que seuls des banques extra
européennes puissent financer des
réacteurs nucléaires qui ne viennent pas
d'europe dans la vision qu'a l'europe de
du nucléaire sur son territoire
c'est quelque chose sur lequel aucune
réponse logique me paraît en mesure
d'être d'être opposées alors je vais
vous dire aux questions de monsieur de
monsieur chauvet pour lui dire je lui ai
dit tout à l'heure que le la manière
dont est né dit ce serait traité d'henri
recul c'est qu'il n'y aurait pas de
changement les inquiétudes que j'entende
aussi de la relève sans doute d'un
manque de dialogue
mais il est en effet difficile d'ouvrir
un dialogue notamment avec les
fédérations concédant ce jeu rencontre
néanmoins dans quelques jours plusieurs
personnes qui sont qui font partie des
concédants lille est difficile de le
faire dès lors que c'est un projet qui
est en cours de discussion et que
certaines des grandes lignes du projet
sont loin d'être acté si je vois si le
gouvernement où edf doit aller au
contact d'interlocuteurs sans être en
mesure de dire de façon suffisamment
détaillée de quoi on parle et va-t-il ou
non y avoir un accord c'est c'est une
discussion qui ne sera pas qui ne sera
pas très très riches mais ce que je
voudrais dire c'est qu'il n'est prévu
aucun changement chez les je les ai dit
tout à l'heure je le répète bien
volontiers le seul changement c'est
connu kennedy sois filiale à 100% d'edf
dont le capital n'est pas détenu à 100%
par l'état mais seulement à 83% par
l'état et les dix seraient filiale d'une
société edf vers filiale à 100% comme
aujourd'hui d'une société edf verts dont
le capital serait lui même détenu de
façon très majoritaire par edf bleu et
par l'état et avec une la volonté d'y
mettre quelques actionnaires
minoritaires donc il y a déjà une
participation d'actionnaires
minoritaires dans aînés 10 il y en
aurait deux mains et les choses ne ne
changent pas j'ai répété aussi qu'à mes
yeux la péréquation tarifaire est pas un
sujet à l'ordre du jour
pas plus que ne l'est le changement des
contrats de concession qui d'ailleurs
ont été signés entraîné 10 et les
autorités concédantes et qui n'ont
absolument rien à voir avec une
éventuelle évolution du capital du
propriétaire des mets 10 et non pas du
capital et non pas du capital d'aînés 10
et enfin vous avez signalé
s'agissant de rte d'éventuels
rapprochements avec grt gaz
c'est un c'est un sujet qui ne touche df
que de façon indirecte et sur lequel je
n'ai pas deux je n'ai pas d'opinion
tranchée je ne connais pas précisément
ce projet et parler de l'emploi jeu
lotois chez edf dépend de l'activité
d'edf notre objectif est que l'activité
d'edf soit plus prospère plus nombreuses
plus forte plus engagé vers l'avenir
plus capable de se projeter sur des
investissements dans le temps long
qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui où nous
mais je rappelle nous avons été dégradés
cinq fois par les agences de notation
une grande partie du travail de la
direction financière et de moi même
c'est de voir quels sont les actifs
qu'on peut continuer à céder sans
toucher au coeur de df demain notre
objectif c'est plus de croissance et
c'est donc plus d'emplois ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il ne faut pas faire des efforts
pour que edf soit à un opérateur avec
une
une production et une ressource humaine
coordonnées harmonisée mais le projet
que nous portons est un projet de
développement du groupe edf en france et
donc de développement de l'offre de
l'emploi en france
d'ailleurs autant chez les prestataires
des déesses qui sont très nombreux dans
de très nombreux domaines partenaire
d'edf que chez edf lui-même et enfin
j'ai noté que vous aviez parlé des
industriels à haute intensité
énergétique dans leur situation de
manufacture yale ce qu'on appelle les à
chevilly ils bénéficient d'un régime
haddock qui a été approuvé par la
commission de bruxelles dans l'ensemble
de l'europe depuis déjà de nombreuses
années et il n'est prévu aucun
changement pour ces industriels
voilà j'ai été un peu longue elle vous
m'aviez un peu bombardé de questions
alors monsieur le président le
bombardement va continuer vous pardonnez
moi parce que j'ai énormément de
questions je pense que vous avez le
record du nombre d'inscrits je vais donc
demander à mes collègues de ne pas faire
de redondance s'il vous plaît et d'aller
au point directement ce que vous êtes
pour l'instant 21 vous être inscrits
alors je vais donner la parole à fabien
gay ensuite à daniel laurent bonjour
madame la présidente monsieur le
président je suis pas si le bombardement
était pour moi mais bon je vais très
vite et je repars revenir sur les
questions qui ont été qui ont été posées
mois ces deux séries de questions vous
le savez notre groupe
ca c est très attaché à l'entreprise
publique edf pas seulement parce que
c'est marcel paul qu'il a créé mais
parce que c'est l'indépendance et la
souveraineté de la france et vous l'avez
roadie la garantie que où que l'on soit
en france métropolitaine ou en outre-mer
on ait accès à l'électricité et à l'
tarifs réglementés d'ailleurs ma
première c'est ma première question
c'est sur le tarif on a une question ou
le savait on traverse une crise
sanitaire et donc sociale la creux vient
de proposer à la ministre est
ministre de l'écologie au ministre des
finances de rhodes lente et le tarif de
1,6 c'est près de 12 % d'augmentation en
deux ans et c'est 60% depuis la
libéralisation du marché
alors qu'on nous avait expliqué que
l'ouverture à des concurrents allaient
faire baisser le tarif de l'électricité
c'est pas le cas donc je voudrais votre
avis est ce que vous considérez que ce
taux augmente à sion dans la crise
sociale que nous traversons est juste et
je sais que c'est pas vous qui l'avez
décidé la deuxième petite question
notamment sur sa sur la crise sociale
que nous traversons les chiffres de
coupures d'électricité ou de réduction
d'électricité eau est énorme en 2019
ses + 30 % est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner les chiffres pour 2020 ça
m'intéresse et je vous dis juste une
chose sûre ça sur les vies je trouve que
la campagne qui a été lancée par edf le
hashtag mais ton pull moi je la trouve
insoutenable et inacceptable dans la
période
il ya déjà 10 millions de personnes qui
sont en situation de précarité
énergétique
il ya plein de gens qui à la fin du mois
sont pas en capacité ne peuvent pas
payer leurs factures d'électricité et
qui déjà mettre leurs pulls et joue
franchement je ne sais pas qui c'est
carrément tessa quelle boîte de com ou
qui sait où mais franchement dans la
situation sociale que nous sommes qu'une
entreprise publique face à moi je joue
ça inacceptable
deuxième de questions pour pas être trop
long je vais pas vous surprendre jean
désaccord complet avec le projet reculer
votre présentation et j'ai pas
l'impression ni d'être un complotiste ni
être ci et là j'ai entendu ça peut-être
que ça s'adresse aux salariés qui sont
mobilisés aujourd'hui comme ce projet et
que je soutiens mais franchement où
c'est pourquoi on a des interrogations
mais parce que le nombre d'entreprises
publiques qui ont été démantelées comme
ça on va de france télécom à gdf
aujourd'hui devenu angie et dont on va
encore vendre 15% des deux des activités
de services mais c'est qu'à chaque fois
qu'il ya un démantèlement une
désintégration ça se passe comme ça il
n'y a pas un autre contre exemple
c'est ça le problème sur les vies et
donc en réalité on va pas privatiser les
pertes et national
nationaliser les pertes et privatiser
les profits c'est qu'on m'a handicapé au
moment où on aura besoin
d'investissements dans le nucléaire
toute sa partie rentable et notamment
aînés 10 et j'y reviens pas et
d'ailleurs je vous demande combien va
coûter le démantèlement des douze
réacteurs nucléaires prévues d'ici 2030
qui va payer parce qu'il paraît qu'ils
aient une discussion avec la commission
européenne que la commission européenne
se dit prête à aider le groupe à quelle
hauteur ou est ce que c'est la france et
les usagers qui vont payer non mais
combien ça va coûter
et pour vous dire et pour finir il ya
une autre orientation possible
c'est aujourd'hui qu'on renationalisé
edf et combien coûterait de racheter les
17%
parce que je vous le dis il ya une
position je ne parle pas de vous et je
parle de la direction technique
jamais non mais je le dise c'est jamais
jamais je me permettrai pas on ne se
connaît pas de la direction d'edf ou
vous attaquez la reine et on est
d'accord mais par contre on va on va
négocier avec la commission européenne
pour continuer ce système aberrant
donc là il ya un problème c'est qu'il
faut mettre fin au système de la reine
qui justement a creusé la dette d'edf et
envisagé la renationalisation d'edf
voilà je suis désolé d'avoir été trop
loin d'avoir pris une minute de plus
mais je vous remercie monsieur le
président et madame la présidente
avec plaisir fabien daniel laurent 6-3
montaugé
oui monsieur le président directeur
général le projet de restructuration
d'edf suscite de vives inquiétudes tant
de la part des consommateurs que des
services publics de distribution
d'électricité je suis là monsieur le
président directeur général derrière ma
collègue en effet l'ouverture de df vers
un actionnariat privé fait craindre des
conséquences sur la dynamique
d'investissement dé nedis la qualité des
services publics à laquelle les
consommateurs sont très sensibles et un
enrichissement du prix envisageable dans
le dos dans le contexte actuel déjà très
difficile je ne vous cache pas que le
manque d'information et de concertation
avec les autorités organisatrices de la
distribution d'électricité électricité
passe très mal
si j'ai bien compris est né dix
devraient rester à 100% une filiale
d'edf vers mais qu'en est il de la
répartition du capital de cette holding
pouvez-vous nous garantir que
l'attractivité d'edf vert pour les
investisseurs ne va pas entraîner une
hausse du tarif d'utilisation des
réseaux pour permettre à une et dix de
relever les niveaux de dividendes versés
edf vers outre un enrichissement du prix
de l'électricité pour le consommateur il
y a des inquiétudes sur une éventuelle
remise en cause des droits de propriété
des concédants sur les réseaux qui
aurait pour conséquence de priver les
territoires des moyens d'assurer la
régulation local de la distribution
d'électricité notamment de pensez vous
pas que le capital des néo 19,2 me
république pour préserver le rôle d
10 dans le système de la distribution
publique d'électricité de même la
péréquation tarifaire avec les
territoires ultramarins et les zones non
interconnectées insulaire sera t-elle
préserver via le tarifs réglementés de
vente pour finir faisons partie du
conseil d'administration de la fnccr
fédération nationale des collectivités
le 20 janvier avec les élus membres et
son président xavier pintât
nous avons adopté une motion pour faire
part de ses inquiétudes
dans un contexte où la distribution
d'électricité est indispensable pour les
activités économiques ça a été déjà dit
la cohésion territoriale et la
transition énergétique
donc vous avez eu connaissance je
présume de cette motion à votre si vous
souhaitez je la tiens à votre
disposition
monsieur le président directeur général
merci merci daniel la parole est à
franck montaugé ensuite s'ils viennent
noël en visio merci madame la présidente
monsieur le président à me regarde ses
effets l'ouverture des marchés de
l'électricité très dogmatique au plan
politique a été un échec
c'est un fait documenté il faut en tirer
les conséquences pratiques aujourd'hui
comme le font avec pragmatisme les
anglais pourtant chantre de cette
libéralisation en régulant tous les
nerfs comme le nucléaire l'électricité
le caractère de bien commun mais dans
l'intérêt général de notre nation on
doit financer les investissements à coût
minime homme donne par des emprunts
d'état à côté du nucléaire et de rte la
pipe de la pépite de ds c'est aussi est
né dix comme rte est né dix gère un
réseau qui a le caractère
d'infrastructures essentielles et les
dix remplit parfaitement ses objectifs
de coût et de qualité de service et vous
l'avez rappelé tout en s'adaptant aux
nouveaux mix énergétique au moment où
tout le monde parle de reconquête de
notre souveraineté industrielle est né
dix pourrait passer dans les mains et
sous la coupe des gars femmes des usa ou
de la chine pourquoi pas oui oui
monsieur monsieur le président les gars
femmes les grandes entreprises
internationale s'intéresse beaucoup au
réseau électrique et on en reparlera
peut-être un peu cas j'espère qu'on en
reparlera pas pour la france
oui je sais pas c'est pas dit à la
légère c'est le risque que le
gouvernement prenne avec hercules
comment pouvez vous couvrir ce risque
majeur dans un contexte de filiales
majoritairement privé privé tôt ou tard
je rappelle quand même que bien le
français devait aussi rester publique
promesses de président de la république
à l'époque que je ne citerai pas on l'a
tous reconnu avez vous pris dans ce
projet la mesure des craintes des
collectivités locales à propos du
devenir de leurs concessions et des
réseaux gérés par un indice dont elle
sommes propriétaires
que deviendra la péréquation tarifaire
vous avez fait allusion quand les
actionnaires privés d'edf vers
décideront de donner la priorité aux
métropoles parce que ce sera plus
profitable pour eux au détriment des
territoires ruraux
quand et comment allez vous associer les
collectivités locales et les français au
développement d'edf que nous souhaitons
intégralement publics donnent toutes ses
composantes je vous remercier si franck
s'il vient de noël par visio et ensuite
micheline jacques par visio aussi
sylviane est ce que tu nous entends
oui je vous entends pas la problématique
de la mise en demeure de la france par
la commission européenne s'agissant du
renouvellement ou de la prolongation des
concessions hydroélectriques
vous avez déjà répondu à bon nombre des
questions je souhaitais vous poser je
n'y reviendrai donc pas merci aux propos
sont de nature à me rassurer
juste pour vous rappeler qu en zone de
montagne ces équipements joue un rôle
qui va bien au delà de l'aspect
énergétique
qu'il s'agisse du soutien d'étiage à
l'irrigation de la pêche du tourisme du
refroidissement des réacteurs nucléaires
ou la prévention des risques
d'inondation les tous les bals gérée et
exploitée par edf joue un rôle qui
dépasse largement ce cadre là d'où
l'inquiétude bien légitime que cette
ouverture à la concurrence suscitait
chez les élus locaux et les populations
et donc suivant cette logique il serait
tout à fait défendable garder ses
concessions dans le giron public
puisqu'elles relèvent davantage de ce
secteur que du secteur marche
jean de services d'intérêt général qui
peuvent relever de la compétence des
états membres conformément au droit
communautaire voilà encore des arguments
pour apporter un peu d'eau à votre
moulin si je peut vous permettre merci
vianne micheline jack qui n'est pas
saint barthélemy mais dans son bureau et
en visio et ensuite
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
président chers collègues je serai très
concise puisque certaines questions ont
déjà été posés un bon collègue laurent
j'aurais aimé savoir est ce que vous
pourriez nous indiquer quel sera
l'impact de la restructuration d'edf sur
sa brosse est celui donc c'est là qu'est
ce que les ce sont les systèmes
énergétiques insulaires
je vous remercie merci beaucoup à
micheline patrick chaize ensuite daniel
salmon
merci la présidente sue président trois
points donc rapide le premier sur
l'inquiétude que jeu sur lequel je veux
insister de l'indication du numérique
dont l'industrie électrique notamment le
dis aujourd'hui on est convaincu la
transition énergétique ne se fera que
par le numérique est donc cette
implication est quand même une vraie
question j'aimerais vraiment vous
entendre sur le sujet deuxième question
ce serait une question très simple mais
à la fois très importante pour savoir
s'ils pouvaient me donner la répartition
financière des trois entités en recettes
et en dépenses
vous l'avez compris à quelques
inquiétudes sur le fait de séparer donc
à la fois les bénéfices et les bears et
enfin une troisième question c'est sûr
notamment la décision de l'état attendu
sur la politique nucléaire
selon vous quel serait le planning est
idéal pour que justement cette décision
soit prise et puis aussi nous donner la
date
jair butoir qui pourrait donc mettre en
difficulté la france si la décision
n'était pas prise en la matière et enfin
dernière question en sous questions
selon vous est ce que les sites qui
pourraient être retenues notamment pour
des opm deux sont aujourd'hui déterminer
si c'était le cas est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire plus merci merci beaucoup
patrick la parole et à daniel salmon
ensuite franck mais non ville
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
président directeur général le tout
d'abord un constat et reculent ce projet
et recul provient à mon avis d'un péché
originel le péché originel si je peux me
permettre c'est la sous-évaluation
volontaire du prix du mégawatt heure
nucléaire qui nous conduit dans cette
impasse qui nous conduit devant ce mur
d'investissements que tout le monde
reconnaît cette situation financière
catastrophique d'edf
donc je ne me serais pas ici le chantre
houle
je ne ferai pas le procès du nucléaire
ça mettrait beaucoup plus que deux
minutes
par contre nous sommes nous sommes
position nous positionner nous
écologistes pour un service public nous
avons toujours été pour un service
public de l'énergie
ceci étant nous nous demandons un peu
plus de démocratie et la démocratie le
nucléaire n'ont pas toujours fait bon
ménage et peut-être à l'épousé vous
pouvoir m'éclairer sur le fait qu' on
nous dit que fera eu des f a déjà
conventionnés avec framatome pour
l'achat de pièces pour les futurs rpm
alors qu'il n'y a pas une validation
politique ou est-ce qu'on en est ce que
vous pouvez nous répondre là dessus
concernant un rapport qui vient de
sortir ce rapport de rtl il ya eu
pouvez vous nous dire ce que vous pensez
de cette possibilité envisagée d'avoir
un mix avec une très grande partie des
énergies renouvelables en 2050 voire
100%
dernière question celle concerne la
centrale de la vire au larivot excusez
moi que l'on nous dit pouvoir
fonctionner avec une biomasse liquide
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
quelle culture serait prise sur quelle
surface et qu'elle provenance voilà
j'aurai bien d'autres questions mais on
va se limiter à celle là mais
merci beaucoup daniel la parole est à
franck mais non ville ensuite évident
renault garabédian merci madame la
présidente monsieur le président ce
projet recule finalement est davantage
une les conditions donc pour vous de de
la révision et de la sortie j'allais
dire du dispositif de la reine qu'un
point qu'un projet finalement
d'entreprises où nous nous sommes bien
évidemment tous mobilisés surtout très
attentifs au caractère
quel que soit le projet le caractère
parfaitement intégré et vous avez évoqué
donc les trois entités
pourriez-vous peut-être nous détailler
effectivement la l'ouverture au capital
envisagée peut-être sur eux des verts
j'ai cru entendre et puis lire
éventuellement
30 70 sous 35 65 voilà et est-ce qu
effectivement dans le projet qui est le
vôtre et qui est bien évidemment encore
en négociation cette part d'ouverture
serait véritablement figé dans le marbre
et autrement j'avais une deuxième
question mais qui a été parfaitement
posée par notre collègue patrick chaize
sur la temporalité nécessaires et à kehl
qu'elle dit dans quel état tu en simple
devrait s'imposer
le renouvellement du parc nucléaire sans
pénaliser et sans bien évidemment en
intégrant les propos de notre rapporteur
daniel grémillet sur cet enjeu de
production et de croissance de
production et de demande d'électricité
dans notre pays
merci beaucoup franck evelyne renault
garabédian ensuite marie noëlle
lienemann en visio remercie la
présidente monsieur le président en 2014
un rapport de la cour des comptes
dressait un bilan
moi je me vois la dresser un bilan de la
stratégie d'edf à l'international
40% du chiffre d'affaires du groupe edf
étaient réalisés en dehors de l'hexagone
un salarié sur six travailler à
l'international c'est à dire environ
26000 personnes alors que pour la moitié
de ce personnel à l'international il
travaillait en majorité au royaume uni
pouvez vous détailler quels sont les
chiffres de l'activité aujourd'hui à
l'international d'edf
quels sont les effets du projet et recul
sur les filiales internationales et
comment cela va-t-il s'articuler autour
de la stratégie cap 2003 30 qui a pour
ambition de tripler les activités à
l'international d'ici 2030 d'edf merci
si evelyne la parole est à marie noëlle
lienemann et ensuite dominique estrosi
sassone je n'aurai pas la cruauté de
rappeler que nos équipes
on va nous opposer la dérégulation de
l'énergie en europe et qu'à chaque fois
les gouvernements successifs de tous
bords nous expliquer mais non c'est pas
grave on arrivera à maintenir le poids
la force ddf et son unité
on voit sur guéret ici un des mécanismes
qu'on a vu hélas dans toutes les grandes
entreprises publiques de service public
existait dans notre pays et donc quand
on vous écoute monsieur le président on
a le sentiment que la réponse hercules
et simplement la réponse fait un pour
essayer d'obtenir la rue négociation de
la reine parce que en fait pour le reste
les deux la seule question pour vous
c'est d'avoir les moyens de votre des
investissements en modifiant la reine de
en ayant accès à des financements
complémentaires
donc moi j'ai tendance à prêts à vous
demander ne serait-il pas préférable de
garder et df et de tenir bourg parce que
et vous commencez à faire des
concessions
puis la fois d'après il faudra encore en
faire davantage car comme vous avez pu
le remarquer la commission de ne pas
aider fl n'aime pas les grandes
entreprises qu'avec des missions de
service public donc que deuxièmement
pourquoi ouvrir le capital d'edf vers
est ce que c'est une demande de la
commission là aussi
quel est l'intérêt que les niveaux moi
j'en vois plutôt des risques parce qu'on
voit quand même quoi qu'on en dise ce
qui serait mis à bas tout ce qu'il peut
être rentable et ouvert au capital privé
dont on nous dit au début il est
minoritaire et de fil en aiguille il
finit par les extrêmement important
enfin je voulais vous demander si
puisque vous parlez des compétences en
nucléaire c'est par là qu'on va voir le
débat sur les choix et mix énergétique
il ya quand même une grande inquiétude
sur la sécurité et pour cette sécurité
jeu
je plais et je crois que ce serait très
important qu'il y ait fait une stratégie
de limiter la sous traitance d'entretien
et de fonctionnement des centrales pour
se doter de personnels permanents sous
statut ayant aussi une des compétences
améliorée et former régulièrement
si beaucoup marie noëlle la parole est à
dominique estrosi sassone ensuite martin
berthet merci madame la présidente
monsieur le président directeur général
je voudrais vous interroger sur la r eu
2020 et connaître la vie d'edf sur la
nouvelle mouture de la r 2020 en janvier
2020 edf avait organisé une conférence
de presse pour défendre le projet de r
e2020 mai edf avait aussi précisé à ce
moment-là attendre les derniers
arbitrages pour se prononcer
définitivement
il se trouve que depuis la crise
sanitaire est passée par là cette aire
eu 2020 est ce qu elle vous paraît
réaliste et pragmatique au regard des
capacités de production réelle
d'électricité notre mix énergétique est
ce que vous ne pensez pas que le
gouvernement a fait un choix d'une
feuille de route très politique mais pas
un cliquable concrètement comme l'a été
d'ailleurs la r e 2012 en son temps où
chaque année des décrets d'exemption
sont publiés comment edf anticipent
cette réforme
alors qu'on le sait est de plus en plus
tous les professionnels de la
construction sont très critiques et
précise que cela aura un impact négatif
très fort en particulier sur la
construction neuve dont on sait
aujourd'hui déjà combien elle est
diminuée
donc sinistrés et puis sur une question
plus directement lié à mon territoire au
département des alpes-maritimes qui se
trouvant en fragilité électro
énergétique qui est symbolisé par la
fameuse ligne boutre carrosse récemment
le délégué rte méditerranée a fait le
point sur la situation et il a dit que
pour le mois de février
sa crainte était importante puisque
plusieurs recteurs vont s'arrêter et si
des facteurs défavorables se greffer
dessus que ce soit une vague de froid ou
l'absence de vent on pourrait connaître
une situation où l' équilibre entre la
production et la consommation sera très
difficile à assurer
il a dit il faut qu'on soit prêt à
réagir c'est ce que l'on anticipe depuis
six mois alors comment rte anticipe
concrètement ce risque de black out pour
les alpes-maritimes tout
particulièrement sur le bout de la ligne
boutre carrosse merci beaucoup
si nous retournons dans la montagne
martine berthet et ensuite pierre
louault ah oui merci madame la
présidente monsieur le président
directeur général dans mon département
comme dans d'autres de montagne les
industries se sont installés au début du
20e siècle au plus près des sources
d'énergie hydraulique pour rester
concurrentiels à l'international est
alors qu'elles sont de plus en plus
chahutée sur les marchés
elles ont plus que jamais besoin de
l'assurance de conserver des coups bas
d'approvisionnement en énergie dont
elles sont grandes consommatrices pour
leur production mais elles ont aussi
besoin de conserver cette énergie verte
qui leur permet une taxation carbone
moindres est à présent une production
d'hydrogène décarbonée il en va des
emplois dans nos vallées je pense à
faire feu à ferropem actuellement par
exemple quel avenir voyez-vous à ses
coûts de l'énergie pour notre sidérurgie
je vous remercie merci le pierlot et
ensuite yves bouloux mes chers collègues
je vous engage un par poser les mêmes
questions en bardeaux 1 voilà pierre
évidence dans 25 ans plus d'énergie qu'à
abonnés plus une mixte énergétique tout
la mobilité tout le chauffage notamment
des habitations passeront par compass
chaleur on sait que les pompes à chaleur
en période de
en froid semaine en chauffage direct ce
qui provoquera du jour au lendemain une
consommation électrique multiplié par
cinq
est-ce que l'ess sera capable de
répondre à cette demande explosive merci
pierre yves bouloux ensuite pierre
kuipers micro il a voilà un ministre ça
m'arrivera qu'une seule fois donc non je
pense que je le pensais depuis toujours
mais je crois que ça
donc madame la présidente monsieur le
président
d'abord bravo pour vos propos très
clairs jeudi dernier devant les
commissions des affaires économiques et
du développement durable de l'assemblée
nationale barbara pompili ministre de la
transition écologique a pour la première
fois évoqué la difficulté à parvenir à
un accord avec la commission européenne
sur le projet et recul à près de deux
ans l'issue des négociations sur est
encore incertaine
à défaut d'accord madame la ministre a
évoqué la nécessité d'avoir un plan b
pour permettre la survie ddf j'aurais
souhaité avoir votre sentiment sur cette
déclaration qu'elle pourrait être ce
plan b elle serait une recapitalisation
merci yves pierre clippers ensuite anne
catherine loisier merci madame la
présidente je suis président directeur
général une question simple sur le fait
qu'aujourd'hui on inviterait les
français à la rouler en tout électrique
est ce que c'est une utopie de l'aveu de
votre belle vue par vous est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est irrationnel et
déraisonnable moi je le pense en tout
cas si je tiens compte du bilan du puits
à la roue du véhicule et est ce que edf
a la capacité
si devant on était toutes les tailles de
fournir l'énergie nécessaire tout au
long d'une année pieman deuxième
question concerne des verts sur les
objectifs que vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure et concernant la méthode et je
n'avais pas évoquée dans les
renouvelables la méthanisation est ce
que vous voyez
quels sont vos objectifs par rapport à
la méthanisation vers l'électricité
merci pierre anne catherine loisier en
bourgogne ensuite jean marc boyer
merci madame la présidente monsieur
président donc en complément de ma
question principale sur la n20 sur le
volet énergétique de l'aéro 20 qui a
déjà été posée juste une demande de
précisions vous avez parlé d'un objectif
donc de déploiement des nerfs à 50
gigawatts en dix ans voire même 100
gigawatts si les investit la capacité
d'investissement est là est-ce que vous
pouvez nous préciser la part de
différents de nerfs danser dans ses
perspectives et notamment dans ce qui
nous intéresse beaucoup les uns les
autres le potentiel hydraulique sachant
que à notre grande surprise on a
constaté que le plan de relance nos
comptes
vise aucun crédit pour le développement
de l'hydroélectricité
merci absolument jean marc boyer ensuite
serge mérillou oui merci beaucoup
monsieur le président vous avez parlé de
l'éolien en mer
concernant l'éolien terrestre face aux
réticences de plus en plus nombreuse
recours et opposition qui fleurissent un
peu partout et les arguments sur les
risques qui sont évoquées sur la santé
sur la dégradation des paysages des
patrimoines etc
les dépositions du président de la
république et du gouvernement sont assez
fluctuante
quelle est la part aujourd'hui fournie
par l'éolien thérèse dans la production
totale d'électricité et quelle est la
stratégie d'eads et f
dans les années à venir dans le
développement de l'éolien terrestre
merci jean marc serge mérillou ensuite
florence blatrix compta à gauche alors
madame la présidente monsieur le
président je ne sais pas si la
commission européenne aime pas et df
mais nous ici manifestement nous aimons
et df
à tel point nous l'aimons à tel point
que nous n'acceptons pas qu'edf puisse
être démantelée parce que c'est bien ce
que nous craignons avec le projet recul
ce qui ne signifie pas que rien ne doit
bouger mais nous nous souhaitons qu edf
reste un vrai pôle public
je voudrais vous dire deux mots sur les
barrages on a eu l'occasion avant cette
réunion de pouvoir en discuter très
succinctement mais je vais pas revenir
sur l'importance des barrages la
souplesse de la production l'importance
que ça dans toutes nos vallées de la
vallée de la dordogne comme toutes les
vallées de france mais je voudrais vous
avoir des précisions sur ce que vous
appelez le régime de quasi régie qu'est
ce que cela sous-entend parce que c'est
la première fois que je que nous
l'abordons
et puis nous n'avons pas parlé d' aider
à face dure est-ce que c'est une motion
qui est totalement abandonnée
voilà donc je souhaitais avoir une
réponse sur ces deux points
merci merci serge fleurence blatrix
compagne termineront avec laurent
duplomb madame la présidente monsieur le
président vous avez évoqué la nécessité
de construire six nouveaux repères
en juillet dernier la cour des comptes a
fustigé la dérive des coûts et des
délais également dans la construction de
le père de flamanville mais aussi la
perte de compétences techniques des
industriels de la filière
et dans ce domaine là aussi la stratégie
internationale d'edf a été prise à
défaut
je pense au réacteur d'une clé polt la
cour relève que les enjeux financiers
sont majeurs au regard du coût de
construction et indique que le coût de
construction de production démantèlement
doivent être prises en compte dans la
décision ou non de construire de futur
the br donc plusieurs questions sur ce
sujet comment analysez-vous cette perte
de compétitivité de la filière nucléaire
comment travaillez vous faire cette
analyse notamment avec les représentants
des salariés sont ils en sont ils
associés à cette analyse de la perte de
compétences et compétitivité et je pense
peut-être conséquence de la sous
traitance évoqués par marie noëlle
lienemann et finalement comment allez
vous prendre en compte ces difficultés
opérationnelles et financières dans la
construction du nucléaire dans votre
projet de planification du mix et large
énergétique à long terme
merci voilà pour terminer je m'attends à
une question extrêmement technique de
notre collègue laurent duplomb monsieur
le président merci madame la présidente
monsieur le président au lieu de
sur comme mes collègues une question
générale qui a une importance importante
même plus qu'importante
je vais et je vais rester sur une
question hyper technique
le président aujourd'hui edf a une façon
très particulière d'accepter la
facturation de fournisseur d'électricité
vous avez deux styles de contrat ce
qu'on appelle les baies g13 qui
correspondent aux contrats
photovoltaïque pour lesquelles vous
envoyer un relevé de production et pour
lesquelles il suffit de prendre se
relever des productions est de vous
envoyer par mail
la facturation et edf s'engagent à 30
jours de vous réglez la facturation que
vous lui avez envoyé tout cela par mail
dématérialisée mais savez-vous que pour
les producteurs de méthanisation
c'est complètement différent vous
envoyez à relever de production au bout
d'un mois et vous demandez au méthane au
producteur de d'électricité par biais de
méthanisation comme vous envoyer le
relevé à 2 heures du matin c'est à dire
sur un mois glissant fac relevé à 2
heures du matin et que vous demandez
pour la méthanisation ce que vous
demandez pas pour le photovoltaïque de
revenir à une facturation à minuit
minuit vous obliger tous les producteurs
de méthanisation de se palucher 700
lignes sur six colonnes de les sommer de
les diviser par 6 parce que 700 lignes à
relever toutes les dix minutes
vouloir obliger de somme et donc de
faire la somme de 700 lignes sur six
colonnes de le diviser par six pour
retomber de minuit à minuit au lieu
d'une facturation de 2 heures du matin à
2h du matin une fois que le producteur a
fait cette somme
il l'a multiplie par le prix garanti de
son contrat que vous avez signé avec un
avenant avec un délai qui est loin
d'être rapide et vous en voyez il faut
vous en voyez alors vous avez fait un
petit progrès monsieur le président il
faut envoyer cette facture par lettre
recommandée avec accusé de réception
il est vrai qu'avec le coc vide vous
avez ouvert la possibilité d'accepter
que cette facture sera envoyée par mail
je voulais d'ailleurs vous remercier de
ce geste gracieux en vis-à-vis de tous
les producteurs de méthanisation
mais franchement monsieur le président
est ce qu'on a besoin en eau 21e siècle
de demander aux producteurs de faire une
somme de 700 lignes sur six colonnes et
de la diviser par 6 puisque vous avez
toutes les 10 minutes et divisé par six
qui redonne une production horaire pour
pouvoir facturer si on veut développer
la méthanisation et surtout la
méthanisation la petite méthanisation
celle qui est sur les territoires fait
part des agriculteurs et non pas des
industriels est ce que véritablement sur
cette question monsieur le président
vous devez pas apporter une réponse je
vous avais prévenu monsieur le président
de la question très technique
voilà monsieur le président on a fait le
tour de toutes les questions vous avez
vu l'ampleur voire de celle ci et je
vous laisse répondre peut-être là par
grands thèmes bien jeu
je ne sais comment faire pour commencer
non je vais pas commencer par la foule
mais je tâcherai de donner la réponse
réponse générale déjà ce sujet dont
j'ignorais tout jusqu'à votre brillante
intervention aux sénateurs je dirais
aussi je suis vraiment très très heureux
de voir l'intérêt de du sénat l'autre
ceux qui ont fait le déplacement ou qui
s'entend là qui sont à distance pour les
sujets d'edf est peut-être en prenant un
petit peu de recul je voudrais vous dire
ça fait six ans que je suis dans cette
entreprise ça fait six ans que je dis
que l'entreprise à une performance de
court terme tout à fait remarquable qui
s'est d'ailleurs je crois à améliorer
pendant cette période mais qu'on a fait
l'impasse sur les questions stratégiques
absolument majeure et qu'à un moment
donné on se fait rattraper par la
patrouille et c'est ce qui est en train
d'arriver
alors on peut dire c'était mieux avant
c'était mieux on est à l'intérieur de
l'europe
on est à l'intérieur de règles
européennes je me suis déjà exprimé là
dessus je vais le le vous le dire une
nouvelle fois nous nous ne nous ne
sommes pas heureux de la manière dont la
commission met en oeuvre les directives
les traiter les textes qui s'impose à
l'intérieur de l'europe
s'agissant d'edf nous estimons que
ne devrions pas être pénalisés par notre
taille dès lors que nous n'en abusent
ont pas et en six ans et d'ailleurs dans
les années qui me précédaient du temps
de de mon prédécesseur monsieur proglio
edf n'a pas été mis en cause pour avoir
abusé de ce qu'on appelle un abus de
position dominante abusé de sa taille
pour mettre mettre à l'écart pour
annihiler les efforts de ses concurrents
ce qui est en train de se passer
aujourd'hui c'est que l'outil mise en
oeuvre dans les années 2009 2010 2011
pour être sûrs que nos concurrents
pourraient avoir
un espace vital pour eux qu'ils
pourraient prospérer cet outil est allé
beaucoup trop loin
nos concurrents vont très bien nos
concurrents n'ont prennent des parts de
marché dans tous les domaines n'avait
pas demandé
oui on perd 80 milles 80 mille clients
shakkour qui peu moins pendant le
confinement de ce que les gens avaient
autre chose en tête
oui nos concurrents se développe dans
tous les domaines des transactions se
font pour des entrepreneurs brillant il
faut leur rendre hommage qui ont pu
entrer sur le tel ou tel parti du marché
qui étaient auparavant sous le monopole
d'edf et vendre leur entreprise pour des
sommes qu'ils en ont fait vraiment des
des entrepreneurs ayant connu la
réussite y compris sur l'aspect
patrimonial à la fin d'une entreprise
industrielle
oui le lean l'innovation existe dans le
monde de l'énergie les clients peuvent
avoir des offres de toute nature avec
des garanties sur plusieurs années et
nos df ne cherche pas avoir le monopole
de l'innovation
même si edf il ne vaut si j'ai pas eu
beaucoup de temps pour vous en parler
par exemple nous venons de fêter début
janvier le millionième client d'edf qui
n'est pas au tarif bleu parce que nous
avons aussi nos tarifs eux nos offres de
marché et nous en avons maintenant plus
d'un million de nos concitoyens de
français il faut confiance à edf sur des
offres nouvelles innovantes
ça c'est très bien mais nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans la situation où nous
sommes au bout de la démarche ou un
affaiblissement volontaires d'edf était
peut-être nécessaire pour laisser cette
concurrence et cette innovation
prospérer et il faut maintenant remettre
les choses en place pour savoir si oui
ou non ça va continuer edf va être
déclassé et tous ceux qui défendent la
situation actuelle des nedis la
situation actuelle de tel ou tel métier
le les concessions hydrauliques sont
parmi les premières qui sont menacés
mais qui dit
de kennedy ce ne sera pas le suivant sur
la liste
il n'y a pas des néo 10 dans les autres
pays il n'ya pas dans les grands pays
d'europe de distributeurs ayant 95 % du
territoire et donc inédit il est
beaucoup plus menacé
dans la situation actuelle qui ne le
sauraient dans la situation des reculs
les jambes ou raconter qui recule ces
menaces au hercules c menaçant parce
qu'on ne sait pas répondre à tous on ne
sait pas répondre à tous parce que les
négociations sont en cours et qu'on ne
va pas négocier cartes sur table en
donnant les points de vue de
négociations sur ces états qui le fait
l'état ne va pas négocier cartes sur
table avec la commission en disant voilà
exactement ce que j'ai racontée aux
parties prenantes française le parlement
les autorités concédantes les
organisations de salariés qu'ils disent
mais pourquoi est ce qu'on ne sait pas
tout le dessous des cartes pourquoi
est-ce qu'on n'est pas nous présent dans
les négociations je voudrais d'ailleurs
vous dire qu edf n'est pas présent dans
les négociations
nous sommes informés par l'état mais on
essaye de faire en sorte que ds
reviennent dans le peloton de tête des
groupes énergétiques européens et
aujourd'hui nous ne le sommes plus
regarder les annonces qu'on fait
d'autres électriciens qui n'ont pas subi
les foudres de la commission au titre de
leurs
position dans leur pays d'origine ou qui
ne suffisent pas aujourd'hui les menaces
de la commission dont je viens de parler
qui cherche à éviter le développement de
nouvelles constructions nucléaires alors
que je n'ai pas son rôle et qu'elle est
supposée être dans la situation de
neutralité technologique
on parlait de taxonomie et c'est une
évidence que que c'est bien ce qui est
en train de se passer
regardez les montants absolument
considérables qui sont me parler mais
d'or pétrolières qui doivent
progressivement migré dans lequel
l'électricité est peut-être le biogaz
des questions là-dessus joueront un rôle
important est la question qui est en
train de se poser et bien c'est qu'au
bout de ces quelques années pour ce qui
me concerne et de dix ans pour
l'entreprise
au bout de dix ans pour l'entreprise il
faut savoir si on garde le statu quo et
qu'on est menacée d'un fort des
classements etc ont mené qu'on est
menacée de devoir vendre un peu les
joyaux de la couronne ou bien si on
arrive à trouver une solution qui est
peut-être un peu compliqué qui s'appelle
hercules et qui est la meilleure
solution qu'on a trouvé tout en restant
à l'intérieur des contraintes
européennes parce que les contraintes
européennes elles sont nombreuses et
elles nous obligent on n'est pas comme
ça tout seul à pouvoir décider ce conte
reprise comme d'ailleurs elles existent
sur l'ensemble des parties prenantes
donc je voulais vous dire que que c'est
un sujet qui me paraît d'une extrême
importance pour l'entreprise que le
dossier est difficile
madame pompili a dit que les
conversations risquait de ne pas aboutir
qu il fallait peut-être réfléchir et
réfléchir à des alternatives
moi ce que m'a demandé le gouvernement
ce que ma demande et même le président
de la république lui-même dans un
discours qu'il a prononcé il ya deux ans
c'était dans les derniers jours de 2018
c'est de préparer une réforme de la
reine et c'est de préparer une décision
dont nous savons qu'elles ne seront pas
pour qu'elle ne sera pas prise
maintenant mais peut-être au lendemain
des élections présidentielles de 2022
sur la construction de six réacteurs
père voilà la mission qui m'a été
confiée par l'état
maintenant sur les points plus plus
précis qui on est et qui ont été abordés
ce qui concerne les questions tarifaires
je voudrais d'abord rappeler que nous
n'avons
nous avons pendant la crise sanitaire
suspendu les coupures
je voudrais aussi rappeler qu'il y a
chèque énergie pour les français qui
vend des ressources limitées qui donc
peuvent bénéficier d'un chèque énergie
qui je crois fonctionne bien
je voudrais rappeler que les tarifs en
france sont nettement moins chers que
dans les pays voisins d'ailleurs ceux
d'entre vous aimez lire là qui se sont
exprimé là dessus qu'ils vivent dans des
zones frontalières il suffit d'aller
demander combien ils payent
l'électricité c'est 20% 30% 35 % plus
cher dans les autres pays
en allemagne c'est 70% donc nous faisons
nous très attention à garder une
économie de l'électricité aussi
compétitive que possible 3 comble nous
le devons nous le devons aux français
nous le devons à tous les français il
n'est pas question de modifier la
péréquation tarifaire ça fait partie des
règles du jeu et donc hercules n'a rien
à voir avec quelque changement que ce
soit pour la péréquation tarifaire ni
sur le territoire de l'hexagone ni sur
les territoires insulaires qui ont été
qui ont été mentionnés par madame
jacques il n'y a pas d'impact des reculs
sur la structure qui s'appelle et ce y
il n'y a pas d'impact des reculs sur la
péréquation tarifaire
ensuite en ce qui concerne le rôle
d'aîné disent vous avez plus été
plusieurs à en parler et j'en avais
parlé dans mon propos introductif
il est prévu un changement d'actionnaire
donné 10 au lieu kennedy je me répète
soit détenue à 100 % directement par edf
il sera détenu à 100% par la structure
des verts l'edf le capital on a été
ouvert une quinzaine d'années nous avons
aujourd'hui en 15 16 % de capitaux
d'investisseurs qui ne sont pas les tad
d'actionnaires qui ne sont pas l'état et
demain il est prévu on a donné un
chiffre de 30% mais il n'est pas gravé
dans le marbre pose par exemple on
pourrait en plusieurs étapes peut-être
pas dès le démarrage
peut-être en plusieurs étapes monter à
30% et pourquoi 30% parce qu'aujourd'hui
la loi française spécifiquement pour edf
les voix que le boulet le public les
structures publiques doivent avoir 70%
du capital et que le privé est limité à
30 donc nous disons bien voilà pour des
verts limitant à 30 ça nous permet de
développer des verts avec beaucoup de
moyens parce que c'est à travers des
verts que le développement d'edf va se
faire pour rattraper les cinq ou six
groupes ce qui sont clairement devant
nous ne sommes franchement menacé de
devenir un opérateur de deuxième zone
on a du mal à s'y faire parce que c'est
la grande des f nous sommes franchement
menacé cela donc le capital d nedis nous
nous proposons par exemple 30% puisque
c'est 30% qui est dans le chiffre actuel
de deux verres pardon puisque c'est 30%
qu'il chine le chiffre actuel d'edf bleu
et simplement et les dix changerait de
propriétaire en ce qui concerne les
dividendes d'edf d'aînés 10 puisque
monsieur laurent en parlait et je sais
que c'est un sujet qui préoccupe
beaucoup les le conseiller lui concédant
que le concessionnaire fasse un minimum
de dividendes je crois que j'entends
souvent les concédants dire ça serait
tellement bien que le processionnaires
face à minimum de dividendes
moi je crois que c'est bien que les
concédants se disent essayons
d'organiser les choses pour que le
concessionnaire fasse un maximum
d'investissement chan tsin
concessionnaires faire je lisais nous
avons largement augmenter les
investissements des néo 10 puisque nous
avons doublé par rapport au point bas
que nous avions connu dans les années
2000 et sur la période 2015 2020 qui ne
concerne que directement
nous les avons monté de 30 % maintenant
si l'idée c'est que le concessionnaire
n'a pas de dividendes je voudrais
comprendre quel est l'intérêt du
concessionnaire à se donner du mal pour
gérer bien sa concession
par exemple les performances de coupure
de courant en zone rurale d'aînés 10
sont jugés comme très bonne par rapport
à ses concurrents dans d'autres zones
rurales parce qu'on va pas comparer la
performance d'un réseau en zone euro
allez on torture ben il faut comparer en
zone rurale et aux honneurs voilà donc
nous nous essayons d'avoir un écosystème
qui fonctionne bien je crois que c'est
celui des néo disent ils et il se
développe à base investissements
importance mais je crois qu'il mérite
aussi quelques dividendes
je souligne d'ailleurs que nombre de nos
concurrents européens ont un taux de
retour du dividende vers l'actionnaire
de 100 % alors que nous c'est 65% et et
voilà qu'il faut trouver il faut traiter
trouver cet équilibre je suis très
heureux régulièrement d'aller à la
rencontre de la fnccr je me souviens
d'être allé dans plusieurs congrès dans
plusieurs réunions dans votre beau siège
social du 7e arrondissement pour parler
de ces sujets là avec avec les
différents dirigeants de la fn de la fnc
sert donc pour il est dit s'il n'est pas
prévu pas prévu de changement je
voudrais vraiment rassuré rassuré tous
nos tous mes interlocuteurs
là dessus je devrais parler je reviens à
monsieur guay mais à d'autres aussi qui
ont parlé de deux nucléaire d'abord je
voudrais rappeler à monsieur guay mais
je ne doute pas qu'il en est un lecteur
attentif que à plusieurs reprises les
rapports de nos commissaires aux comptes
des rapports de la cour des comptes ce
sont des rapports commandés par le
ministère de l'énergie se sont penchés
sur les prévisions pour démantèlement et
qu'il est je crois a admis que nous
avons et ce même si ça a pris un petit
peu de temps c'est vrai nous avons au
fil du temps mis de côté au moins ce
qu'il faut aujourd'hui c'est à peu près
103% 104 % de ce qu'il faut pour
démanteler gérer les combustibles de fin
de vie après la fermeture et que donc
nous avons fait le devoir qui nous avait
été imposé par une loi
d'ailleurs un peu tardive une loi qui
est postérieur à la loi la cour de
construction de des centrales nucléaires
de façon à correctement démanteler les
choses et que ceci est inclus je
répondrais notamment à monsieur à
monsieur salmon
la de là dessus est également jeu que
ceci est inclus évidemment dans les
coûts du nucléaire
nous allons déposer un dossier à la
demande du gouvernement pour proposer la
construction de six nouvelles centrales
nucléaires le gouvernement décidera si
le cea-leti disent ils estiment que
cette nécessaire ou pas dans le cadre du
rapport rtl yeux et dans d'autres cadres
nous avons déjà dit que nous pensons que
c'est indispensable si on veut avoir en
france un système électrique qui
répondent à un certain nombre de
questions majeures et en particulier
celle que je disais tout à l'heure
quel est le degré d'acceptation des
alternatives notamment en matière
artificialisation des sols
quel est le l'impact sur le pouvoir
d'achat de ceux privés de nucléaire
quel est l'impact sur les risques de
coupure quel est l'impact sur les sujets
de souveraineté et d'emploi donc nous
allons répondre publiquement dans
quelques semaines lorsque nous y serons
invités par rte sur ces fameux scénario
2050 et nous espérons que les op r je
réponds aussi à monsieur mais non ville
que les deux pères pourront être
décidées le plus vite possible
gouvernement souhaite que ça ne soit pas
un débat d'avant les présidentielles
mais une décision
l'abbé bacon on verra bien les décisions
d'après les présidentielles nous nous
souhaiterions qu'elles soient prises la
plus vite le plus vite possible parce
que nous estimons que la filière
la filière nucléaire nécessite une
continuité d'activité comme vous le
savez la filière nucléaire française ce
sont 220 mille emplois il faut une
continuité d'activité beaucoup de ces
emplois sont logés dans des entreprises
qui souffrent aujourd'hui des
difficultés que j'espère conjoncturelle
mais qui semble quand même duré plus dur
et sur quelques années dans la filière
aéronautique et donc nous avons un tissu
industriel qui est fragilisée par la
crise économique née de la pandémie et
nous aurons
nous aurons quand même besoin le plus
vite possible une visibilité là dessus
et je répondrai également à monsieur
chaize que nous avons fait savoir par
une décision du conseil d'administration
que les premiers sites retenus seront
seront le site de penly le site de
gravelines le site de bugey et le site
de tricastin le choix entre bugeat
tricastin se faisant ultérieurement mais
j'ai reçu des à plusieurs reprises
d'ailleurs des élus de ces quatre de ses
quatre parties du territoire ces quatre
zones du territoire qui se félicitait en
tout cas où ma présence de voir à
certains moments de très grands
chantiers venir animer de la vie
économique de leur région et je
répondrai d'ailleurs aussi à monsieur
salmon que oui nous avons eu
l'autorisation de la part du conseil
d'administration d'edf d'engager la
fourniture la construction de certaines
pièces en avance de phase et aux risques
d'edf de façon à ce que les op r s'ils
sont décidés puisse être construit dans
de meilleurs délais que si si une telle
mesure n'avait pas été prise et et ceci
va d'ailleurs se traduire assez
rapidement par des travaux dans
certaines usines de notre filière l
filiale framatome monsieur chaize vous
m'avez aussi demandé pour la répartition
financière entre les trois entités c'est
quelque chose que nous ne pouvons pas
vous fournir aujourd'hui puisque les
négociations n'ont pas ne sont pas
terminées sur les questions de prix de
valorisation est donc ce qu'on appelle
le business plan le plan d'affaires de
des différentes entités du futur groupe
intégré est quelque chose que nous
partageons évidemment avec tout le monde
le moment venu c'est simplement c'est
simplement
c'est simplement prématurée je voulais
répondre aussi à monsieur salmon que
pour le larivot
nous avons donc obtenu toutes les toutes
les autorisations des différentes
instances de la république qui ont à en
connaître que ce soit au niveau national
que ce soit le préfère que ce soit au
niveau local et que donc le chantier va
bientôt commencer et or ce qui concerne
le combustible nous appliquerons la
réglementation européenne red 2 qui vous
permet d'avoir une biomasse liquides
dont les sources agricoles enfin dans
l'est dont les produits de base sont
limitatif et en particulier n'inclut pas
le culture à base d'huile de palme dont
c'est l'application de la biomasse
liquide telle qu'elle est définie dans
la directive européenne
réd 2 voilà je crois avoir répondu à
beaucoup d beaucoup des questions
j'avais une question de madame lienemann
sur la sécurité du nucléaire je voudrais
je voudrais souligner même par rapport
aussi au reste de son intervention que
nous avons évidemment nous mettons un
grand soin parce qu'à l'intérieur des
règles du jeu qui proviennent des
directives européennes et en particulier
celle de 97 et 99 en matière de
l'ouverture des marchés de l'énergie le
nucléaire puisse en permanence
bénéficier d'une gestion très attentive
en matière de sûreté
ce sont pas des installations comme les
autres et donc à ce titre
l'autorité indépendante française qui
s'appelle qui s'appelle l'asn a
évidemment des pouvoirs extrêmement
important d' enquêtes d'inspection
d'injonction que nous respectons de
façon scrupuleuse et je voudrais
souligner la nature très étroite des
relations aux techniques des partages
d'informations qui
associe à l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
et le respect scrupuleux de toutes les
prescriptions par edf il nous est arrivé
d'être pénalisés c'est rare mais ça peut
arriver par l'autorité de sûreté
lorsqu'elle estime que nous n'avons pas
fait ce que nous aurions dû faire
et bien nous nous battons notre coulpe
et nous appliquons les décisions de
l'autorité de sûreté qui je crois très
très respecté en français et dans le
monde
madame estrosi-sassone vous aviez des
sujets sur l'équilibré offre-demande sur
le territoire des alpes maritimes
c'est un vieux sujet dont j'avais déjà
entendu parler il a bien bien longtemps
et dont je crois qu'il a été très
largement résolue en enfouissant et non
pas en laissant en aérien
la liaison qui à un moment avait été
envisagé pour traverser une partie du
parc naturel du verdon et finalement
ceci a été fait il reste quand même des
éléments de fragilité
c'est à rte de les gérer comme vous le
savez ce n'est pas à aider f de les
gérer
mais si nous pouvons aider art et à
trouver des solutions qui rendent un peu
moins fragile ses parties les plus
extrêmes du territoire et nous aussi les
soucis sur la bretagne
edf fera le maximum pour trouver de
bonnes solutions pour faire que
lorsqu'il y à des risques sur l'ensemble
du territoire il n'ya pas des risques
accrus sur notamment le département que
vous représentez et puis j'ai eu des
questions sur les questions de
2h20 donc pour vous dire qu'en effet il
semblerait que les la décision
définitive après consultation du
gouvernement soit imminente
ma connaissance elle n'est pas prise la
n va va permettre au français de faire
ce qui se passe dans beaucoup d'autres
pays c'est à dire de faire une migration
ordonnée vers des systèmes de chauffage
dans lequel le combustible fossile est
donc très émetteurs de co2 comme le fuel
le gaz ou le charbon sont
progressivement remplacés dans la durée
par des combustibles
ils n'ont émetteurs alors il peut y
avoir un peu de biogaz c'est vrai le
biogaz aujourd'hui on a eu des chiffres
très récemment un représente à tout
petit pourcentage c'est moins de 1% de
la consommation française
j'ai compris que le ministère et je n'ai
personnellement pas d'opinions négatives
à ce sujet que le ministère cherche à
peut utiliser le biogaz de façon
privilégiée là où il n'y a pas d'autres
substitution il n'y a pas de
substitution possible au gaz naturel et
que les implications du biogaz pour
l'électricité
mais là je parle vraiment sous réserve
de ce que le ministère est ce que madame
pompili andy doit doivent ne doivent pas
être encouragé parce que comme il ya peu
de biogaz il faut le réserver à d'autres
usages
pour revenir à la rfa 20 il y à un sujet
qui je crois inquiète les professionnels
de la construction et qui n'a pas grand
chose à voir avec edf c'est celui des
obligations de matériaux biosourcés ça
c'est un sujet savoir avec quoi on
construit de quoi sont faits
voilà nous nous c'est nous notre sujet
c'est plutôt profitons de cette
réglementation pour substituer au gaz
qui est devenue une une source
d'émissions tout à fait considérable au
fil du temps dans les logements pour
substituer à ce gaz de l'électricité des
carbonnais comme nous savons le faire en
france nous avons 95 % d'électricité
décarbonée en france je crois que c'est
le mouvement qui est en train de suivre
l'état avec une mise en scène une mise
en place progressive de du moyen de
chauffage par de l'électricité bio
carbonée ou par de la biomasse assez
rapidement ce qui concerne les maisons
individuelles et un peu plus tard ce qui
concerne les logements collectifs
je voudrais aussi souligner ça n'a pas
été que ça n'a pas été dit que les
pompes à chaleur sont une industrie
française avec un très fort contenu en
emplois et peut donc la r 20 20 va
contribuer à ce que l'un d'entre vous a
cité la réindustrialisation à plus de
pompes à chaleur ça veut dire plus de
réindustrialisation en france et ça veut
dire aussi évidemment moins d'achat de
gaz de la part de nos partenaires extra
européens vous même les plus beaucoup de
gazon en europe
monsieur cuyper m'a demandé si est-ce
que c'est déraisonnable d'envisager de
rouler tout électrique
certainement
toujours déraisonnable de dire qu'on
sait ce qui va se passer dans un temps
par contre qu'il y ait par contre qu'il
y ait un mouvement absolument
incontestable du véhicule des véhicules
thermiques vers le véhicule électrique
la réponse est oui nous nous avons pris
un engagement chez edf sait que tous nos
véhicules légers les petits véhicules
d'edf délai dissocie des engagements
avaient été pris également chesnais 10
seront tous électriques en 2030 pour les
petits déplacements pour les grands
déplacements
quelle sera la bonne solution quel sera
le rôle de l'hydrogène restera encore
est ce qu'il restera encore pour
quelques temps des véhicules thermiques
est-ce qu'ils sauront quelle sera leur
de leur niveau de propriété ou de
partage puisqu'on on est aussi dans un
monde où on partage beaucoup les choses
je ne suis pas un grand expert et des
prophéties à 25 ou 30 ans en quelquefois
sans quelquefois difficiles à faire et à
votre question
monsieur mérillou sur la quasi rigide
edf azur le lac aziri j ai le moyen
juridique pour isoler le parc
hydroélectrique français était là quasi
régie qui est gérée comme une quasiment
comme une régie de l'état quasi régie
c'est quasiment comme une régie de
l'état c'est à dire qu'en fait l'état il
joue un rôle tout à fait prépondérant et
pour que ça fonctionne il faut que
l'état détienne à 100% la quasi régie
soit directement soit indirectement dans
notre schéma c'est indirectement à
travers la société la société mère edf
voilà je ne sais pas si j'ai encore
trois minutes monsieur boyer m'a posé
des questions sur le développement
d'éoliennes terrestres français
il est il est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le
développement de l'éolien terrestre en
france se heurte à des réticences dans
des régions qui n'en n'ont pas des
régions qui en ont et qu'ils trouvent
qu'ils en auront trop qu'ils en ont déjà
trop et le leulier difficile je crois
pour la france de tenir les objectifs
qu'elle s'est fixés en matière de
développement éolien terrestre nous
avons plutôt pris du retard par rapport
aux trajectoires qui était envisagé par
ministère de l'énergie
il y à il y a quelques années il ya une
piste qui est intéressante c'est ce
qu'on appelle la rénovation des
installations existantes peut-être en
augmentant un petit peu la hauteur des
mâts mais d'utiliser des installations
qui ont été créés et quand leurs
capacités individuelles étaient de
l'ordre de 1 mégawatt et quelquefois
moins parce qu'elles peuvent avoir 10 ou
15 ans au bout d'un certain temps on
peut les changer et mettre des turbines
qui sont trois fois plus puissante
quatre fois plus puissante pour
améliorer la production
c'est peut-être ça va ça sera peut-être
une façon de rattraper le retard qu'on
est en train de prendre sur les
trajectoires en matière d'éolien
terrestre qu'on avait envisagé à
l'époque et puis je terminerais donc par
les relevés production photovoltaïque
versus les relevés de production
méthanisation et monsieur du plomb ne
m'en voudra pas si je lui dis que la
réponse lui arrivera mais pas
immédiatement parce que je n'ai pas sur
le champ
la réponse à votre question et jeu et
notamment et notamment j'aimerais savoir
et notamment j'aimerais savoir si ce que
nous faisons vient des services de
f où vient des biens de la manière dont
la commission de régulation de l'énergie
nous demandent de comptabiliser ses
installations et je n'ai pas la réponse
voilà donc on joue on voit là on voit là
vous vous expliquerez et puis on
essaiera de comprendre si c'est une
bureaucratie
parce que c'est comme ça qu'il faut la
décrire qui a été créé à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise ou bien si ça nous est
imposée pour que vous ayez le droit aux
aides
parce que je ne connais pas la réponse
monsieur le président sans habits de
votre temps je crois que martine berthet
voudrais que vous lui confiez renier que
sur les électro intensifs il arrive
d'électricité strictement aucun
changement nous sommes très attentifs
aux aux électro-intensifs ce sont des
emplois industriels très important avec
avec beaucoup de valeur ajoutée beaucoup
de technologies des dispositifs ont été
mises en place pour que les électrons
intensif payent l'électricité une
fraction de ce que payent de ce qu'ils
paieraient s'ils n'étaient pas
considérés comme électro intensifs et il
n'est prévu strictement aucun changement
dans le domaine et le
le dossier hercules la réforme du mode
de régulation d'edf la réorganisation
des activités les moyens dont on a
besoin pour rester dans la cour des
grands ce sont des sujets qui sont
totalement distincte du sujet des zones
industries électro-intensives voilà on
ne touche à rien et je crois comme dans
beaucoup de domaines anne-catherine
rapidement avoué vous venez de nous dire
sur les éoliennes comment donc comptez
vous atteindre les 50 gigawatts on voit
les 100 gigawatts
alors les cendres les 100 gigawatts donc
donc pour les 100 gigawatts et bien
c'est une vision d'abord d'edf dans
l'ensemble de sa quels sont les quels
sont les secteurs qui vont croître il
d'abord l'hydraulique un peu nous avons
des projets de déploiement de deux camps
d'installations hydrauliques de barrages
hydrauliques supplémentaires
deuxièmement il ya aujourd'hui des
développements extrêmement rapides dans
le domaine de l'énergie photovoltaïque
et dans le domaine des éoliennes en mer
hélas les les coûts considérablement
baisser vos concevons continue a
considérablement baissé
la puissance des machines en mer d'un
considérablement augmenté elle a déjà
commencé à augmenter considérablement
et c'est là que sont nos principaux
gisements et nous avons aussi des
gisements ce qui concerne l'éolien
terrestre mais nous considérons que
l'acceptabilité l'éolien terrestre est
un véritable sujet que donc nous
comptons dessus mais de façon je dirais
mots durs et très bien merci monsieur le
président merci de cette longue audition
vous voyez que effectua dernière
avant que je conclus en quelques mots
daniel ça va être très bref à ce que ça
a été introduit par le sénat sur le
texte énergie climat
ces deux bilans carbone sur le
renouvelable savait qu'on est très
attaché et effectivement on va atteindre
la neutralité carbone mais si c'est
faire du renouvelable avec des produits
d'importation lorsqu'on fait des bilans
c'est pas terrible
or les derniers appels d'offre merci
madame la présidente de me redonner la
parole sur ce point là mais c'est du
concret le très concret c'est de la fin
de l'année 2020 les derniers appels
d'offre démontre qu'on a un
accroissement énorme de réponse de et
qui ont été satisfaites sur les
investissements qui vont être réalisés
sur du photovoltaïque produit avec des
panneaux venons d'ailleurs de la france
et de l'union européenne
donc on a un peu toujours là mais vous
avez raison de ce grémillet nous sommes
tout à fait en est tout à fait inquiets
du fait qu' il n'y a pas de
comptabilisation carbone de dans les
importations fait en particulier sur ces
sujets là donc nous avons demandé que le
rythme lors des prochains appels
d'offres
il y est un critère carbone en
particulier sur les sujets d des
cellules solaires